vraiment pas faire play
les ordures pareil on les connaît
ah c'est une grosseur du race et ça joue
encore ouais c'est franchement les gens
comme ça c'est démoralisant en fait
enfin genre tu as tenter ton piège je
suis pas abandonné
je me barre frère je me barre
complètement en fait j'en ai absolument
rien à [ __ ]
[Musique]
où es-tu
coccinelle
je suis très heureux de ma connerie
quand même dommage 4 h 5 d'un F4 H4 dans
H5 excusez-moi messieurs dames c'est un
peu trop fort pour vous quand même
non non
je fais de la daube en fait pourquoi
j'ai pas encore gagné la partie pourquoi
j'ai toujours pas gagné là mais non mais
quelle connard qu'est-ce que j'ai foutu
j'avais qu'à gagner en fait je sais pas
ce que je suis allé [ __ ] j'ai voulu
faire j'ai voulu faire oh oui bah voilà
merci Monsieur j'ai voulu faire dans la
beauté et le faussement sentimental la
machette je kiffe
coucou
bah moi alors je tricote
j'avais pas vu qu'il y avait la dame en
un
[ __ ] je suis une trompette
les amis quand on voit ça c'est
c'est stratosphérique en fait c'est
hallucinant c'est
c'est impossible de jouer à leur niveau
en fait c'est incroyable oh la coup de
défense le cavalier F7 machin et tout
recent tempo oh il y a tout ça mat
ça c'est ma tendance
oh le malaise
oh la tristesse du coup que je vais
jouer oh la tristesse oh fermez les yeux
oh
oh la tristesse du coup
oh le fou qui va revenir en vie via oh
il peut pas revenir oh la tristesse du
Fou bordel on sait même pas comment il
est venu là oh
évidemment
c'est un coin intermédiaire quand même
relativement à la con
j'ai pas l'idée sur dame F4 mais j'ai
peur
c'est 5 direct
non
je me suis fait ma tête il se passe quoi
si je fais
j'ai pas
c'est roi F1 seul coup [ __ ] il l'a
mais cavalier c'est 4 protège le Punto
quand même important important
pour trois attaques il va faire un échec
en B8 merde j'avais je suis un connard
je suis un connard j'ai cavalu prend B6
je suis une merde je suis une merde je
suis une merde je suis une merde comment
je le vois pas comment je le vois pas
comment je le vois pas ce [ __ ] de coup
la position va encore mais j'ai plus
assez de temps
ça envoie que pour quoi ça clique très
fort il y a cavalier c'est deux
chasse la Tour Eiffel je monte le roi
je ramène le cheval sur une belle case
mais je laisse une tour je laisse un
cheval en un mais je laisse un cheval en
un mais je suis une merde allez essaie
de faire nul là-dedans mais c'est pas
quoi sur dame prend des cinq ça
s'appelle une gaffe ça il a oublié de
prendre F6 oh bah ouais oh bah ça fait
plaisir là ok bon je sais pas comment me
remotiver là pour remonter
c'est incroyable qu'est-ce qu'il est nul
ma donne
Madonna qu'est-ce qu'il est mauvais
[ __ ]
non [ __ ] mais c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible
[ __ ] mais c'est n'importe quoi c'était
juste dame
il le voit pas je me suis fait matrixer
et je me fais ma tête en un [ __ ] je me
suis fait matrixer
il voit pas le match
j'ai failli abandonner je pensais qu'il
se foutait de ma gueule
d'où l'intérêt de se [ __ ] de la gueule
les adversaires après ils peuvent
abandonner en pensant que tu te fous de
leur gueule bah ouais mon chat
oh non oh non je rappelle le grand rock
j'ai raté le grand rock
à la main je me barre j'en ai rien à
[ __ ]
non
il a raté
il a vraiment raté fou prend un 4
nodio qui l'a raté
il a oublié de faire tourner 4 moi
j'étais dans l'idée comme les coups
viennent par grappe qui avait tombé 4 et
H4 et qu'il avait obtenu la position
mais la page 4 direct et il a raté Jules
oh le malaise
[ __ ] il a raté il a raté une tourelle
en un
matin 7 ouais alors
erreur de retransmission attention
[Musique]
ah ça y est oups
je vois pas d'autres options que ça du
coup il a pas d'âme des cinq j'ai été 5
il a pas de case
oui enfin ça ça s'appelle une dame is
ski bon il propose nul maintenant oui
bon ok ça s'appelle une dame Nicole the
Queen oui bon il fallait faire nul quand
je t'ai proposé tout à l'heure connard
quand même
Descartes qui prend des cartes à me
prendre j'ai trois cavaliers de ah mais
je suis pas protégé mais je suis con
c'était juste pion prend F2
je vais ramener le cheval
ça s'appelle une tour désolé concoursing
il est où mon petit chaton mon petit
poulet a baissant qui donne un pion bon
pourquoi pas bah écoute tu donnes un
pion je le prends ça c'est annoncé je me
lasse quand même fou et si ça se
s'appelle une tour après oh bah oui mais
bon attention ça c'est encore les
cloises oh bah oui bah écoute je suis
pas cloué merde
c'est le piège à la con je vais me le
prendre je le sens je l'oublie toujours
ce piège je vais finir par me le
reprendre
oh bon oui bon si c'est ça le piège ça
va quand même
et merde mais non mais c'est encore une
pièce pourquoi je dis merde ah merde
on va switch pour 5
pourquoi je switch 5 bordel de merde
pourquoi je switch ou alors français 3D
4 x 6 dames prends roi des 7 à 4 dames
prends un cadre d'un me prend ok il fait
ça mais ça c'est une dame frère
qu'est-ce que tu fais
retourne bouffer tu as fondu dégueulasse
ou ta tartiflette là frère
fait beaucoup trop plaisir pour pas la
jouer merde
voilà cette dame prendre B7 et fou B5
peut-être
[Musique]
bon vieux temps pour C8 c'est fois 6
frères t'as pas vu
ça ça s'appelle une dame entre jackpot
donc une matinée une matinée quand même
constructive ce matin déjà donc une
équipe qui commence à se construire tu
vas juste avoir un champion du monde de
Blitz un triple champion du monde de
Blitz une double championne du monde
ça pose les bases d'une équipe en fait
c'est bon qu'est-ce qui se passe tu vois
ces gens on vient on nous a appelé ouais
bon on est là si vous voulez [ __ ] des
mères faut nous appeler parce qu'on va
venir quand annonces dans ton équipe
salut tout le monde et bienvenue pour ce
live que j'ai lancé un tout petit peu
plus tôt sur la chaîne de chascom pour
que vous veniez avant avant le foot
c'était un peu tard pour pour envoyer
des Red sur ma chaîne etc donc j'ai
lancé un tout petit peu plus tôt ici bah
juste après juste après la finale de la
Coupe du Monde bah un peu le SAM un peu
le SAM évidemment
même complètement et on va on va suivre
on va suivre 4 heures de speechestre
derrière ouais je suis complètement
aigri on sera avec Fab qui sera encore
plus et gris mais qu'est-ce que ça tombe
mal dans le calendrier là c'est
après une finale comme ça je crois qu'on
peut pas faire pire évidemment peut-être
fier pour les Français que pour les
autres mais clairement
après tant d'émotion ça va être
difficile de de vibrer pour autre chose
bon on fera ce qu'on peut je pense qu'on
discute un peu de la finale avec Fab
aussi de comment il a vu le match
après les Belges d'avoir le seum pendant
4 ans
Piou Piou Piou on a quand même gagné une
Coupe du monde et on vient de faire une
finale de Coupe du Monde bon je veux
dire voilà au bout d'un moment faut
quand même reposer les bases il faut
quand même
c'est ouais
non quand même c'est ouais le niveau de
ça mais quand même pas le même
on est quand même des gens sérieux le
seum qui commence déjà non mais on est
bon perdant on va pas commencer à te
parler de possession ou de machin bon on
a perdu on a perdu hein on n'est pas on
n'est pas des aigris
on me son visage ouais mais ça va on a
quand même deux étoiles sur le maillot
frère
ça va t'inquiète t'inquiète de français
bon perdant bah ouais le français se
sait supérieur
ouais quand tu perds alors que tu as
jamais rien gagné ça donne un autre
niveau de ça moi c'est ça
à 20h 20h minuit
j'aurais pu commenter j'aurais fait 24
heures de speech
sur sur cette semaine plus de speech que
de coupe du monde
on verra on verra le match de ce soir ce
que ça donne après speechestre ça
reprendra j'imagine l'année prochaine
donc le match qui commence dans trois
quarts d'heure vous avez un favori pour
ce soir vous vous en foutez enfin je
sais pas
c'est bientôt les championnats du monde
de Blitz c'est du 26 au 30
je pense à la 120e
en fait il peut gagner c'est là-dessus
qu'on perd le match enfin ok le match il
est long et tout mais c'est plus que la
séance de tir au but c'est ce moment là
on pouvait marquer
je pense ouais je crois que pour nous ça
tombe vraiment mal trop d'émotion sur ce
match qui était quand même d'anthologie
avec avec le scénario
avec près le scénario de ce match c'est
sûr c'est difficile d'avoir des émotions
de se chauffer pour une autre
compétition
la faute de Dembélé au début du match
ouais
bah après je sais pas si affreux ou pas
on peut faire deux trois Blitz en
attendant comme je disais d'habitude je
fais un raid tu commences sur ma chaîne
mais là il était trop tard pour faire un
live de 40 minutes et repartir du coup
on va on va le faire ici vite fait
je sais pas si je vais réussir à Blitz
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai lancé en
avance mais si ce que je me suis en fait
si on lance pas en avance les gens ils
vont ils vont partir faire autre chose
pas de regret ouais c'est comme ça on a
perdu on a perdu il faut être il faut
être bon perdant aussi
il faut être beau joueur
on est quand même beau joueur les amis
non on n'est pas beau joueur vous n'êtes
pas beau joueur
bon on est pas beau joueur c'est comme
vous voulez
c'est un match de Mbappé par contre bah
ouais ouais il met il met trois buts
forcément
c'est fou d'ailleurs cette programmation
du speech qui est tombé tout long
sur sur la Coupe du monde alors là ils
ont pas mis le match en même temps mais
quoi qu'il en soit ça tombe un peu
dessus dans le sens où
par la finale c'est fini il y a deux
heures enfin je sais pas tu as
as
bizarre la programmation du speech je
trouve cette année
bizarre d'être tombé comme ça autant sur
la Coupe du monde pendant le truc
ok je vais
ok en fait
c'est plus fou j'ai 4 qui m'inquiète ici
est-ce que je serais pas en faire en
train de faire complètement de la merde
très possible
ouais je suis en train de faire
complètement de la merde en fait
parce que Madame elle est très mal
placée
je vais faire B3 mais j'aime pas du tout
ce coup
c'est bizarre ce que je suis en train de
faire ce que je me mets dans ce
vis-à-vis
autant dire que ça allait pas du tout
enfin j'étais un peu obligé je pense
j'ai tellement mal joué avant
il parle du principe que les gens que je
joue au foot aux échecs ouais mais en
fait je sais pas j'ai l'impression que
la Coupe du Monde tu as même moi je
regarde pas le foot normal mais les
derniers matchs regarde j'ai pas pu
regarder la demi parce que c'est le
match de Maxime tombé pendant France
Maroc au moins mon event il tombait
enfin moi mon event tu pouvais pas le
déplacer en fait
et là la finale elle n'était pas du tout
prévu dimanche de base en fait ils ont
déplacé leur finale pour qu'elle tombe
sur la finale de Coupe du monde
moi mon event j'étais j'avais pas le
choix c'est un événement qui demandait
qui demandait énormément de
d'organisation
ok il fait torcer 7 je vais faire
tourger 3 mon idée c'est d'essayer de
défendre latéralement
je pense c'est bien joué pour G3
ah ça c'est pas mal joué de sa part
aussi
ouais ça fait mal ça
je vais devoir prendre ici quoi qu'il en
soit
et je vais faire Dame des deux mais
ouais ça je vais faire dame prend j'ai
pas le choix
il a bien joué
il a très bien joué
mais vu après je pense pas que je le
rejoue par principe déjà il a un petit
élo pour son truc en plus
des fois il insulte quand il perd j'aime
pas trop
ok je vais faire tourner
ok je vais faire ça de roi F4 Dame des
deux ou trois
oh ça c'est bien joué
ça c'est bien joué
j'avais pas vu le 5 j'aurais dû mettre
le rond en C3
en fait le problème c'est qu'il y a dame
de maths au prochain
j'aurais dû mieux me concentrer
ça m'aurait permis
de jouer deux trois coups de plus j'ai
mis match
ouais c'est bizarre en fait j'étais pas
loin de
en fait je vais pas je vais pas réussir
à bien jouer en fait j'ai pas du tout
envie de jouer
j'ai pas du tout envie de voir des
chèques en fait donc ça va être
compliqué
donc ça va être compliqué
OK
bon on va se développer
envie de rien faire c'est horrible bon
si c'était que blitzer ça va mais suivre
tu veux une compétition d'échecs là
c'est pas trop le
c'est pas trop le bon tempo en fait
d'ailleurs mamie Caro à Twitter ça va
être dur de faire aussi bien si en fait
même les Américains qui regardent pas de
football
flemme de jouer après cette belle finale
c'est que
c'est que c'est vraiment compliqué pour
tout le monde
il y a personne dans le chat enfin ouais
c'est jusqu'à tard en fait
ok je vais faire pousser 5
en fait c'est pas très grave si je
reprends le G
okay 5 je pense qu'elle prend puis on
prend qui est BK
si on prend cavalier prend la dame est
enfermée
après lui c'est sûr qu'il faut jamais le
jouer mais
c'est bête
en premier
mais ouais je suis bête de jouer contre
lui
je suis tellement con
prêt à [ __ ] ouais mais faut 3 il était
pas obligé de prendre
c'est ça le problème
je pense pas qu'il est fou pour un H6
ici quand même
ok il a ça comme ça j'aurais dû
commencer peut-être par cavalier B4 mais
je
suis pas absolument sûr que ce soit si
grave
si on prend cavalier branche je peux pas
éviter de me faire mater c'est
incroyable ça
j'ai commencé par cavalier B4 du coup
waouh
il a tellement bien joué
bon je vais pas rejouer évidemment
c'est que première ligne de l'ordi tout
le long c'était très beau
à partir de à partir de de
cahier des 5 c'est tout premier en ligne
tout le long
mais lui il peut faire des très
mauvaises parties de faire des foules
première ligne connu pour pour ça
normalement je ne joue pas je sais pas
quoi je l'ai pas bloqué encore peu
importe mal on va essayer d'avoir un
autre adversaire
mais c'est joli ce qu'il a fait
c'est joli cavalier F6 puis on prend de
mj6 ou F6 maths
peut-être ou pas peut-être ils l'ont pas
écrit sur le titre mais c'est 20h
ok bon allez on attend une autre game
bon j'attends une game
voilà ce qu'on a une game
ils ont bien ok ok ouais non mais ça
débute du coup ça débute dans 30 minutes
on attend on a hâte d'être minuit
tu seras en congé ah non championnat du
monde de Blitz avec plaisir
le 1 semaine de congé en fait c'était
cette semaine pas insensé être mais du
coup j'ai fait 24 heures de commentaires
de speech plus tout le boulot que j'ai à
côté j'ai encore fait une semaine à 50
heures sur ma semaine de congés donc
la date demain ouais ah bah ouais moi je
suis content la semaine prochaine là
c'est une belle semaine j'ai rien de
spécial à faire on va pouvoir vite
tranquille le soir et tout ça va être
magnifique ça va être cool
des congés sans lettres ouais et en fait
c'était une des pires semaines de
l'année mais c'était censé être une
semaine de congés ouais
allez on va attendre on va attendre la
prochaine game
de la France oh non Stone là on a on va
repartir on va repartir sur du mieux
juste là le scénario du match est
tellement terrible en fait si on perd de
zéro et que et qu'on a pas le frisson en
vrai il y a
en vrai il y a c'est juste que ouais ça
la défaite fait mal parce que
parce qu'on y croit quoi
bon j'ai pas d'adversaire en plus c'est
tellement la Hess
la dernière seconde le gardien sera un
arrêt alors qu'on l'a pas vu tout le
match ouais
après je suis pas sûr qu'il tire
vraiment bien l'attaquant
c'est que le moisi je pense je suis pas
je suis pas sûr qu'il le tire bien
mais là
c'est comment elle peu importe
j'ai même pas de Game quoi c'est
terrible
c'est que le moyen est-ce que je pensais
mais Laurie sur les tirs au but c'est
pas possible en fait
il fait systématiquement de la dobbase
en fait
je crois qu'il sait pas faire de fin de
corps Loris tu sais toujours de quel
côté il va plonger j'ai l'impression
j'en ai en fait que tu as des gardiens
ils sont très marlouis ils font un ils
se déplace vers la droite et il saute à
gauche et j'ai l'impression que Loris en
fait quand il commence à sauter vers la
droite il va systématiquement à droite
j'ai cette impression
Loris les peaux c'est pas son truc après
tu peux pas être bon partout Loris c'est
un excellent gardien il a fait un bon
match globalement
il peut trop rien faire sur les buts et
il a quand même été propre sur sur le
reste
je vais faire dame j'ai 6 ou d'un F5
plutôt
je comprends pas trop ce qu'il veut à
vrai dire
je vois pas trop où est le problème
bien fait pour vous les Français non
mais frérot enfin c'est pas c'est tous
les Belges vous vous humilier encore
plus à venir avec votre somme là
ok je vais faire ça pour essayer de
mettre mes pions sur blanc et peut-être
naviguer avec le cavalier en C4
je vais tenter de faire à 3 et B4 en
fait
ah du coup je vais jouer un peu la casse
C4
pas mal joué le B4 je m'y attendais pas
en fait j'ai pas anticipé que le
cavalier pourrait venir en D2
il va quand même avoir du mal
là je fais complètement de la merde
tu auras 7 pour tout racisme c'était un
peu con
bon je vais revenir vers ces quatre
peut-être
je suis quand même très fixé là à 3
c'était une connerie un très clairement
je vais essayer de venir là
avec le cheval
je suis complètement foutu
ah oui mais c'est vrai ok peu importe
peu importe on va essayer de la défendre
le cavalier C4 est pas si mal je vais
mettre une tour en G8 sinon je vais me
faire ma tête
si je joue très vite je pense qu'il va
avoir du mal à cliquer à la fin
OK
faut être fuite c'est pour attaquer le
pion et couvrir
est-ce que j'ai [ __ ] je pense hein
parce que si il fait tout rage de tour
ici qui va aller F4 tourner 6 le
cavalier loin du Fou
donc il doit pas pouvoir l'attraper et
s'il fait tourpoint F5 je vais faire 3G
6 quand même il aura encore tours C5 qui
est chiant
mais après je pense que j'ai pas trop le
choix ça c'est tout aussi se forcer
je crois pas que
soit bon
je vais faire roi G6 quand même j'ai
hésité
mais je veux jouer pour le pion F parce
qu'il est hyper fort ce pion passé
je vais faire tout Revin
pour tour B1
et peut-être vous serez
OK
on va mettre le cavalier en B6
mais bon cavalier au 5
et on est perdant mais on gagne autant
cavaler 17 échec qui a fait mal mais bon
on a passé quand même la victoire
ouais juste le petit truc intéressant
sur cette vieille bon la partie était de
très mauvaise facture mais juste une
fois qu'on a le pion F passé après à la
fin fin c'est vraiment une arme très
forte parce que les Blancs ont du mal à
passer leur pion a et le pion F est
proche de dames
et là je crois que tout Reims c'était
assez bien joué ouais c'était le premier
coup de l'ordi j'avais bien fait de
m'arrêter là
je pensais qu'il ferait cavalier des
trois et j'ai essayé d'évaluer ce truc
là
je sais pas ce que ça va aller
mais je pense ça a gagné parce que j'ai
deux pions passés éloignés du coup leur
dit quoi
ah alors dis fait AB intermédiaire c'est
B on apprend B2 OK et sur cavalier
revient du coup B prend a ouais ou même
B6 en fait
j'ai pas de cavalier E5 je peux pas
revenir ok intéressant ça
et donc là gagné au noir avec F4 et sur
A5 F3 ça prise B2 prise B2 prise B2 si
il fait à 6 il y a cavalier C4 revient
ok intéressant
lui il joue pas
c'est un joueur qui me gêne beaucoup
OK
il joue cette variante
que je trouve relativement bizarre
ok j'imagine
je peux mettre le cavalier juste en D7
je crois
quand même de base quand tu fais G3
c'est pour mettre le four en G2 donc je
suis pas mécontent que le fou soit
décalé
mais là on va faire à 6 maintenant
OK
il y a plein d'options et j'aime bien
que si on prend je calculais un truc
avec puis on prend puis on prend des 7
dame prend roi qui est des seins croisés
6 qui est C3 il y avait un truc assez
long
mais ouais même si l'échange les dames
je suis pas forcément contre et là du
coup je vais partir pour grand rock
ça me paraît assez logique mon roi est
quand même bien placé j'ai beaucoup de
pions autour de mon roi là mes trois
puntos sont pas mal fou ici ça me gênait
c'était le coup qui me gênait le plus à
vrai dire
je vais quand même envoyer le cavalier
en H5 parce que sur fu G3 je pense que
j'ai cavalier prend et surtout D1
attendez on me gêne
cavalier prend F4 tout reprend des 7 il
prend deux tours des 8 3 prend des 8
prises 2
et sur dams et 6 du coup qui va être
joué
c'est cavaliers F4 prise cavalier 2 ça a
pris ça
du coup je vais venir je vais aller voir
la variante va être un peu longue
je vais quand même faire foudre ici
puis mettre mon four en E5
[Musique]
je pense que j'aurais pu faire mieux je
me suis un peu avoir par cette ligne
ça je vais faire roi E7 pour couvrir
je veux pas le laisser rentrer je vais
passer mon fou en E5 qui tape le fond le
5 est bien placé
OK
je vais prendre de l'espace normalement
il va partir pour cavalier géant
cavalier F6
j'ai pas le temps d'un BK puissant
je vais revenir vers B6
ça j'ai vu
complexe que je suis en train de faire
je veux pas lui laisser monter le roi
OK
c'est hyper complexe
merde j'ai plus de temps
je me suis foutu mal au temps alors que
je joue bien
quel dommage
en fait j'ai voulu faire une bonne game
let's go
il est écrit le joueur américain et grid
ah bah ouais ça fait plaisir quand même
oh bah là il doit être aigri l'Américain
oh il doit pas être bien chess whe weeds
ça fait plaisir quand même il fallait
s'imposer
ça joue la pendule quand même que
j'ai eu du bol avec le pat
parce que il jouait clairement le pack
le frérot
un Argentin ah bah ouais mais bon c'est
quoi dire argentin là c'est argentineau
américain de chasse waves
elle était marrante la finale en fait
c'était pas mal le fou prend H2 de lui
laisser le fou pour
pour aller grailler les punch
juge j'étais un peu lent mais après j'ai
eu le bon réflexe de monter le roi oh
bah ça rejoue
mais c'est un adversaire qui me
qui me réussit pas à pas généralement
[Musique]
c'est pas mon ouverture ça
je crois que je peux faire qu'il y ait
des cinq
pouvez mais ça peut servir à grand chose
je vais prendre je vais faire des quatre
maintenant
j'ai envie de faire 5 mais je suis pas
sûr
c'était mal joué
j'ai raté ce coup
j'ai juste raté ce coup
que je vais tenter ça
j'ai une idée mais bon
[Musique]
j'avais une idée je voulais faire un
truc avec dames des 6
du coup je vais prendre ici
il peut même faire pion prendre parce
que sur Dame des six il a tour des 8
OK
bon j'ai pas roi H2 il
a pas faire roi J2
mais comme je vois pas comment je tends
3 H2 dames roi dame de roi H1 il a pas
d'âme G2 maths il doit faire pion prend
et du coup à ce moment là j'ai dame 2 ok
donc il fait ça
ok je vais faire dame de juste
bon là je me suis bien couvert
je suis pas sûr de ça
je ne suis pas sûr
OK
bon là je suis bien
ça va pas suffire
ça ça peut pas suffire
OK
ouais dommage plus assez de temps pour
la gagner
mais il m'a manqué là j'étais gagnant
ouais j'aurais dû faire ses prends des
cinq intermédiaires ah le con ça c'était
terminé
il a troll en face non il a voulu jouer
le temps à la fin
et du coup ouais après j'aurais
peut-être dû faire [ __ ] à 5 ici
deux fours j'aurais pu tenter un truc
comme ça mais bon dans tous les cas
j'allais gratter les puntos et faire nul
parce que le roi revient et c'est sur
casse blanche
je vais essayer de choper Fab
allez j'ai le temps pour une dernière
game
on va récupérer
le match
on a commencé un peu en avance pour pas
que vous ratiez
je sais pas pourquoi je fais ça
ok bon je vais prendre F3 sur échec du
coup je vais pas c'est bizarre fout ces
trois
c'est bizarre
ouais moi je vais mettre le pion j'ai 6
il crée quelques petites menaces
ça se peut que je me fasse ma tête en
fait
j'ai envie de m'amuser je vais faire
dame prend H2
ça a pas l'air de marcher en réalité
ouais ça s'appelle
ça ça perd
voilà
je vais tenter encore tout j'ai encore
ton TF6
j'aurais dû jouer plus vite mais bon
avec tous les trucs que j'ai sur l'écran
bien joué ça
je vais appeler Fab
je vais terminer merde
tu m'entends
je t'entends pas
mais tu vas m'entendre
mais ça va marcher alors
ça marche
ça y est on a perdu
pas tu allô allô tu m'entends
je vais mettre le design ça va ça va
non ça va un peu quand même
non non
c'est comme ça un peu de Somme quand
même vite fait
non non j'étais beaucoup plus énervé de
la prestation incipit des compagnies
finalement bon il y a eu un combat et
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
n'a pas volé son match parce que
ça aurait pu
par miracle bravo il était très grand
[Musique]
bon l'arbitrage bon c'était terrible
mais c'est la vie c'est comme ça
mais c'est ouais bon c'est la vie en
fait je veux dire mais qu'est-ce que tu
veux dire
sur le match d'Argentine a été plus
forte en fait mais ça aurait vraiment pu
tourner parce qu'à un moment ils sont KO
debout et c'est dommage
quand à ce petit opportunité de pas y
arriver mais faites pas trop tu vois tu
peux rien dire même la dernière occasion
de que le moisi il tire bien en fait
c'est le goal qui fait un méga sauvetage
donc
ok voilà des fois faut se reperdre c'est
la vie ouais c'est la vie c'est la vie
et c'est vrai que ce speech du coup qui
tombe une programmation
qui est pas un grand fan de foot
dit dur de passer après ça quoi
[Musique]
c'est dur d'avoir une pierre
programmation en fait d'ailleurs tu as
un peu tous les sports qui ont essayé de
justement de pas se programmer
non mais vraiment bah oui oui c'est
normal en fait mais c'est con parieur je
sais pas j'ai pas d'explication mais
c'est ouais
bon alors attends je crois que les
parties ont commencé mais ça pas ça m'a
pas mis le follow
était pas bien parti et il me manque
plus que ta cam ouais je l'allume j'ai
pas ton partage juste pour dire
en fait un peu tous les sports qui ont
essayé de
oui mais là en fait tout le monde
regarde ça et
en plus pas de chance il y a des
progressions ça fait une tarte tu as pas
le temps de te remettre complètement et
tu as envie de dire autre chose que
juste que je comprends pas pourquoi ah
ok ça y est j'ai compris
pourquoi est-ce que
attends j'ai
Obs qui me fait un petit truc pour ta
cam donc je vais je vais me
tu veux qu'on lance la cam sur un autre
programme
donc je vais le je vais le refaire
toute façon après la partie se passe pas
non plus masse de choses
parce que je vois c'est assez égal
on est côté Carlson ouais ok
maxime m'a dit que ça pourrait être
pliée assez vite après lui le match de
ce soir
mais je trouve qu'il joue très bien
et déjà même si Naka joue très bien le
problème c'est quand Carsen joue bien il
est en dessous et en plus je trouve pas
que Naka est déprime un grand niveau de
jeu dans les tours précédents quoi
après bon des fois ça peut tourner tu es
une partie Audi au début peut-être que
tu fais douter ou que sais-je quoi mais
oui ça peut aller vite effectivement je
suis d'accord avec Maxime plus dans un
sens que dans l'autre
le match
je vais pas lui en vouloir
non mais bon j'annonce quand même
normalement oui ça
ça suit une finale aujourd'hui mais pas
forcément la même
plus importante que l'autre
bon je suis désolé je finis juste de
manger
après je suis à fond tu appelles ça des
cuisses de mandarines ouais
moi c'est joli les cuisses
tu as raison je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai repris l'expression mais je trouve
que c'est une belle expression et cuisse
de mandarine
c'est magnifique en fait sont une
quartier quoi et les gens ils disent des
talons aussi quoi ça se trouve c'est
une expression de synthèse
les gens disent quartier aussi
d'ailleurs même des quartiers genre
ils sont très énervés
du 9 3 t'es pas bien quoi enfin non mais
là pour le coup en fait ça se trouve
c'est vraiment une expression débile que
j'ai sorti mais c'est parce que 40 ans
j'appelle ça comme ça quoi en fait donc
c'est les nazis je suis de santé j'ai
jamais entendu ça quoi nous sommes
ça me paraît très naturel perso mais bon
tu as les gens ils disent je vais dire
cuisses aussi maintenant ah bah voilà on
va lancer un truc quoi et c'est beau des
cuisses de mandarine
en fait c'était juste tes parents qui
disent ça ils savent même pas pourquoi
c'est même probable
c'est juste un truc de ma famille quoi
non mais c'est une belle expression
aussi c'est vrai qu'une fois que tu l'as
dit tu dis oui c'est ça ressemble un peu
à des cuisettes quoi
bah je sais pas pourquoi ça sert à rien
comme ça mais
jamais questionné pourquoi ça serait
comme ça ou pas bon un petit matin
qui attend le tour des 8 moi j'espère
une victoire de Manu je te cache pas
pour un gros score on en parle plus hein
grosse score genre dans une demi-heure
il y a déjà trois points d'écart mieux
pas du tout ouais le massacre quoi
sa petite parenthèse enchantée au niveau
football là
[Musique]
le passage à mon avis doit être complexe
tu passes de Mbappé
[Rires]
dans une semaine ça il faut charbon quoi
ah ça doit être fou
[Musique]
tu passes de top mondial à 1008
feater je dis cuisines de mandarine
aussi ok ça va il y a pas que moi au
moins quoi
donc c'est une expression de santé voilà
c'est beau on apprend des mots
mais tu as souvent des belles
expressions
quoi ouais je le fais pas de gaieté de
cœur
et ça c'est de santé aussi
super vigilant quoi je dis que de la
merde qu'en fait je crois que c'est
normal je crois qu'il y a que toi qui
dit je fais ça de cœur mais maintenant
je le dis aussi je suis très heureux
connu mais bon je connais personne qui
le dit quoi enfin peut-être connu parce
que je vous l'ai dit quoi aussi
c'est connu de gaieté de cœur ouais
enfin
un quartier de parfois plus un éclat un
coussin une cuisse quoi
c'est beau un coussin
la gueule mais tu pourrais presque si tu
étais un playmobil quoi
oui c'est beau tu auras des gamins ils
vont jouer au Playmobil ils vont mettre
leur Playmobil sur des petits coussins
de mandarine quand ils vont être très
heureux
à la petite Micha pour qu'elle s'allonge
dessus oui madame
mais ce qui va la tenir en fait où il va
finir par la perdre
ça va peut-être répéter mais je sais pas
enfin là
mais il était peut-être un peu mieux
quand même
oui
je sais pas à quel point il y a vraiment
des chances ou pas enfin bon
pas tant que ça parce que en fait c'est
pas le genre à faire des nuls cadeaux
normalement et il a une bonne technique
en finale donc il y a du juger qu'en
fait
nous on l'aurait jouait parce qu'on est
con quoi donc on comprend pas moi je te
la joue quoi vas-y
Marina c'est quand même assez rare fable
cette indienne à ce niveau
de rentrer là-dedans alors ça c'est un
truc nouveau de se fout des trois fou et
deux ça a l'air complètement débile mais
il y a des mecs qui l'ont joué là tu
joues une potion avec un temps de moi
mais bon
pas parler sur une vidéo une fois où tu
disais ouais bon c'est complètement con
mais c'est fort
je sais pas à quel point c'est fort mais
genre l'ordi aime bien il y a des bons
joueurs qui l'ont joué mais c'est
possible j'en ai déjà parlé mais en fait
moi j'ai eu cette position avec les
noirs et il y a déjà rock avec les
blancs en fait ça c'est la partie de
carwana qu'on avait montré là où il y a
de la paire de fou pour et sur des 5 bah
en fait non tu as ça avec un temps bon
les blondes genre ok alors peut-être
Carlson le montrer que de ne pas ok tu
vas faire des h3g4 des trucs mais je
pense pas enfin à moins qu'il y a
quelqu'un
proposer l'échange des fous qu'il faut 3
bon je crois qu'il allait à 6 personnes
voilà qui a eu des deux fous des 7
j'imagine ça peut être la suite et
peut-être il va faire G4
et bref donc oui c'est assez étonnant
comme variante je veux dire
c'est pas censé trop marcher comme ça
mais il se trouve que ici
particulièrement mais c'est ordi quoi
ouais c'est ordi
pas des trucs que j'aime
ouais mais maintenant c'est les échecs
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire c'est
devenu ça
j'aime bien des fois la subtilité par
exemple la partie robinstein où il fait
fouter 5 provocat 6 pour venir en
Détroit ça je comprends pourquoi tu
perds un temps parce que le pion raciste
et il peut pas jouer avec cassis avec le
pion à 7 et faire B6 machin enfin il y a
une vraie explication facile là je suis
incapable de dire pourquoi je sais que
c'est possible c'est vraiment flou et ça
marche pas
capable de vraiment l'expliquer enfin
peuvent te l'expliquer avec des
variantes concrètes d'ordi mais je vais
reparlerai que c'est possible qu'un
intellectuellement ce soit pas
compréhensible mais bon c'est les échecs
modernes c'est comme ça non
grotesque dans plein de variantes bah là
je comprends ça provoquer un coup un
coupon mais en fait il se trouve que
c'est pas si mal que j'écarte en fait
c'est un coup jouable donc après
finalement il joue avec grand rock ouais
mais c'était le soleil explication je te
disais qu'il est peut-être possible
c'est que finalement tu dirais j'ai pas
fait petit rock mais toi ça ça
après
c'est juste pas clair pour moi en fait
genre de position
parce que parce qu'en fait la taille
blanche je trouve pas qu'elle va être
trop violente parce que ton tel Fg7 tu
es jamais matte en fait mais tu as pas
genre un truc rapide genre F3 H5 damage
2 genre moi ça me ferait vraiment peur
mais bon je sais pas plus rapide en fait
faut voir si tu joues pas avec les Noirs
ça va être la merde mais le ça me fait
d'enlever la Tour Eiffel 8 au pire sur
damage 7 tu auras toujours la fuite donc
tu es pas encore maths et de deux tu
peux aussi prendre de F en G6 et virer
le fou et défendre via la 7e rangée quoi
mais oui il faut quand même regarder
enfin c'est sûr que les blancs ils vont
quand même essayer de te rentrer un peu
dans le lard et puis voilà quoi
tout bien tout honneur ils ont quand
même de l'attaque avec un fou qui peut
arriver en H6
souvent tu te fais un peu prendre à la
gorge quoi
j'ai toujours un énorme réticence à
faire j'ai 5 côté noir voilà ce qu'il a
réaction pour bloquer le jeu pas se
prendre d'attaque mais tu as la case F5
quoi ça fait quand même mal quoi
donc il va là c'est bien joué de la
partie Carson en fait il veut peut-être
repartir
mettre les tours en B1 C1 avoir le Joal
eldam classique à 3 B4 machin s'il veut
un jour plus qu'à idéal qui a lieu trois
qui est 5 jours ou qui a eu deux qui est
G3 et donc j'aime bien comment il joue
là le 5 de Naka je veux dire
stratégiquement
ça fait peur de faire est-ce qu'on peut
dire est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'il joue
comme un genre de ruisse quoi stratégie
de blocage
d'antigieuse il a plus aucun plan avec
les Noirs il espère juste tenir ouais
c'est beau quoi il se fait de l'antijeux
et très ruizeste ouais bon bah en fait
c'est peut-être même mieux noir parce
que du coup le mec avec les Blancs il
s'énerve
parce que bon bah voilà il a joué il
s'énerve et toi tu le contre
disons en fait le pion à deux sera un A4
je crois que tu vas tenir avec les Noirs
parce qu'il y a pas de rupture mais là
le fait tu es à trois B4 potentiel même
dans 50 coups en fait enfin un jour ça
pose un petit problème au noir quoi
après un accueil s'est mis en place pour
que ces trois bouches il est B5 et donc
tu vas faire quai ici 7 il va commencer
à menacer ça et pour provoquer à 4 et si
les blancs font à 4 je pense que ça va
quoi
peut-être
mais peut-être que la
[Musique]
4008 le foin
tu tiens ta qu'à se faible tu défends
tes trucs tu la file les sacrifices G5
et ça valait alors lui faire 4 donc un
peu plus peut-être mieux jouer hein pour
le coup parce qu'il veut son baisser 5
et je crois qu'il va y arriver et qui
c'est 7 donc on va voir
on va voir c'est intéressant en fait
accélère la manœuvre et qui fait P4
lui-même
donc là à vrai dire il menace peut-être
B5 pour faire une stratégie d'antiges
mais avec le pion à 4 qui va se faire
manger
non c'est bien joué son Décathlon j'ai
pas spécialement vu mais peut-être que
du coup c'était mieux de faire glisser
700 et 4 enfin moi ambitieux mais
vraiment un petit jeu quoi
et là c'est peut-être pas assez un petit
jeu non
mais bon est-ce qu'il a lu le livre de
Ruiz
je suis pas sûr
il va se prendre B5 je pense oui
finalement c'est comme si on a fait B5
nous-mêmes et qu'on ouvre un peu la
colonne pour ouvrir le jeu
à trois ça a l'air bien aussi
une horreur
est appuies les carpent peut-être te
faire tomber les deux tu auras bien
mais c'est
il protège son pion c'est bien joué
il va faire tomber deux tours bien je
pense
ça va être du obstacle
à tout moment
je serais vraiment dégoûté dans les
noirs
enfin ça me fait ça m'embête trop de jeu
comme ça
je préfère garder du contre-jour mais je
sais rien enfin
au truc où les mecs serrer les fesses
comme ça et puis c'est par perdre bah ça
peut c'est une partie qui ressemble pas
ta face
[Musique]
il donne tous l'espace à gauche à droite
machin au centre ils vont au bout d'un
moment ça craque quoi
et ce qui veut pas essayer B5 c'est une
qualité ou un truc finalement mais bon
ça a l'air
très difficile il a l'air content il
fait un peu le suricate
écoute on va voir il est pas bien après
bon c'est on sait que c'est un bon
défenseur donc il y a peut-être trouvé
une petite ressource ici ou là
oui bon tu es pas bien quoi
peut-être il veut gagner le pion à 4
mais bon
OK
c'est quand même pas idiot mais
peut-être je peux prendre deux B passer
le fond à 5 te mettre en B4 faire un
truc un jour un truc vite fait mais bon
ça a l'air hyper fort
mais tu peux pas faire un truc genre le
plan de fab
tu peux ça c'est un plan de femme non
c'est un peu un plan de faible
je crois qu'il va essayer de doubler les
tours sur Anne quand même
il sait qu'il est pas trop bien mais il
va essayer de te mettre les barbecues
il doit pas être bien quand même
malheureusement on peut pas l'empêcher
en fait ce plan donc
il veut pas quand même il a le temps
c'est grave en fait tu peux mettre
mais il a plus trop de temps il est pas
bien ma gnous
F3 et tu chasses
pas bien en fait
il a super mal joué la Magnus
qui va revenir un F6 il va pas être si
dégueulasse quoi bah ouais mais je crois
qu'il a vraiment mal joué
ah mais c'est dommage parce que ça
laisse tomber trop il y a plutôt penser
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu de
choc des deux côtés
les blancs qui réussissent à taper
tout ce qui pouvait espérer avoir je
sais pas ce que ça va donner mais
là en fait juste tu vas souffrir alors
je sais pas ça se trouve ça va tenir
mais peut-être qu'il pense qu'il va
tenir ça
parce qu'en fait le fouet 8 il tient
mais c'est ça mais bon
état
d'entrée mais à un moment il va
peut-être te faire ces 5 mec finalement
pour créer un pion passé ailleurs
ouais mais pour le moment c'est pas un
peu pleutre côté Magnus quand même
ça purifie un peu mais il a plus de
temps et il pleutrifiable
[Musique]
évidemment tu as pas hyper envie tu
aurais voulu gagner différemment
il va faire
j'y ai pensé mais maintenant tu
finissais
4h
et puis en fait
tu peux pas faire mieux tu as trouvé un
fou de merde arrête elle veut prendre B5
peut-être mais bon non il veut
temporiser il veut gagner du temps je
pense déjà
pour le Bullet ah bah ouais mais bon il
s'en sort bien
mais écoute il a bien mis les Marvel
bravo
automatiquement
OK dans le chat on peut regarder on peut
on peut savoir facilement si on veut
savoir on peut savoir
ben peut-être ça peut être si simple ce
match parce qu'il Caro il a plutôt bien
défendu
franchement
stratégiquement dominée mais solide
mais il a raison de pas jouer au 4 enfin
c'est à chaque fois que tu joues le
Marshall contre Magnus tu ça se passe
bien pour personne en fait ce truc là
pour plus tard du grand miroir des
jeunes c'est quoi mais Maxime il s'est
vraiment empalé dans le dans l'espagnol
de de Carlson
il ajoute trop bien en fait les
Espagnols Magnus ouais trop fort
trop fort dessus c'est peut-être le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps sur
sur ça
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont cassés
les dents dessus et on voit mal quand on
le battre en fait c'est chiant
j'ai l'impression qu'il comprend tout
quoi
ok bon c'est plus dans ces positions là
que tu peux avoir une chance de
ou alors il veut vraiment juste serrer
la vis
et
sans les violettes quoi
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit meilleur
ambulette en fait
non mais bon
c'est complexe
classique de Gambie Damas accepté quand
même
ils ont pas encore pris en D4 mais je
veux dire par là c'est un type de
position à quelques nuances près tu l'as
souvent
donc c'est bon relativement égal mais
c'est ça joue en fait
les Noirs
tu le mets sur la grande diagonale donc
il pourra aller vers C6 ou alors une
autre idée des fois c'est enlève la dame
tu mets les deux tours au centre et puis
au pire il va en 8 il en met personne
et il sera prêt à bouger plus tard quoi
une interfèrent pas avec les autres
pièces que je veux dire
quelqu'un
en fait
je sais pas je peux aller voir si tu
veux
à mon avis c'est pas ça le propos enfin
je vois le message de chat après je sais
pas
[Musique]
de qualification mais en gros ils vont
peut-être n'importe quoi
voulez-vous ça c'est OK
en fait ils ont viré le grand chastours
qualificatif
en fait de soi mais s'il refont leur
Grand Prix avec des mecs éliminés qui
jouent quand même et qui alors là c'est
non alors là en fait tu as tout un tas
de tournois ou tu as une moyenne
au-dessus de 25 50
mais en fait c'est n'importe quel
tournoi qui peut le devenir faut faire
une demande à la FIDE
concrètement et donc tu marquerais des
points
donc classement et après sinon les
places tu en as trois à la Coupe du
Monde ouais j'ai vu une hello c'est ça
une ouello une pour le perdant du machin
et deux au grand Suisse mais c'est avec
ça non et donc celle des tournois machin
là il y en a une avec un tournoi débile
OK et
je pense comprendre peut-être qu'ils
veulent parce que ça fait un moment que
bon bah même nous le dit que ça manque
d'ouverture en fait et que tu as déjà
qui ont pas leur chance et là on peut
dire bah ils ont calé faire les open ils
ont leur chance donc ça va mais
en fait enfin pourquoi pas refaire à le
truc à l'ancienne avec les intervenants
les trucs comme ça et tu auras tes gens
qui se qualifieront
mais il faut quand même qu'il soit pas
n'importe quel tournoi qui puisse
décider du jour au lendemain en faisant
une demande à coucou on peut être
qualificatif quoi enfin
faudrait peut-être pas ça 12 joueurs
comme dit 20 20 en vrai ce serait 12 ou
tu gardes comme ça mais tu fais trois
Grands Prix Fides en fait et le grand
vainqueur du premier Grand Prix qualifié
le 1/4 de seconde est qualifié et puis
voilà enfin c'est pas trop dur à faire
ça tu refais tes trucs avec tes poules
les machins si tu as envie et c'est très
bien enfin c'est pas très bien enfin on
fait comme on veut mais tu prends le
même format que ce qu'ils avaient et
t'en fait trois comme il disait et
justement car chaque est qualifié
tu es juste facile vous avez déjà le
tournoi j'ai déjà le format ils avaient
après après je trouve que trois la Coupe
du Monde et deux au grand Suisse ouais
je sais pas peu importe
c'est quand même un peu des tournois
semiloteries quoi à chaque fois
en fait si tu veux pas la loterie tu
prends juste la météo bah oui mais bon
pourquoi pas juste faire le vélo du coup
enfin c'est pas con moi j'ai rien contre
ils font comme ils veulent non mais tu
pourrais mettre tu pourrais mettre par
là on a souvent discuter mais oui tu
pourrais mettre 12 places en mettre 5
comme ça et puis cette eau et l'eau et
pour être hello tu es obligé de jouer 45
parties classées ou 50 parties classées
dans l'année 50 parties classées c'est
pas énorme enfin si tu es joueur pro
c'est normal de jouer 50 parties donc
dans l'année quoi enfin c'est mon métier
quoi d'ailleurs même pour
même constat pour le championnat de
France tu as des plats la souris l'eau
je pense faut jouer un an minimum de
parti bah 50 c'est bien enfin j'ai ok
waouh toi tu peux décider que c'est 45
ça c'est c'est pas 10 en tout cas oui 50
c'est 6 tournois de 9 rondes enfin ok si
en 12 mois tu joues pas au moins 6
tournois pourquoi tu joues enfin
ça me va tu pourras laisser que c'est 40
enfin peu importe je m'en fous mais un
nom quand même relativement conséquent
tu peux pas juste rester chez toi être
assiette ton hello à pas bouger allez
faire deux parties de ligue pour pas
être sorti de la liste et tiens regarde
mon hello quoi
mais
oui je comprends pas en fait pourquoi on
donne quasiment aucune importance au
vélo si en fait est quand même le truc
qui est le plus significatif de ton
niveau au final honnêtement en plus tu
peux prendre une moyenne de l'autre
prend pas forcément la liste je pense je
sais pas quand tu dis bah sur sur un an
on prendra les moyennes et puis voilà
et que vous devez jouer tant de parties
et puis voilà
hello pas spectaculaire je pense au
contraire
de tennis en fin de saison en fait tu
prends les 8 meilleurs bon c'est pas le
vélo c'est le classement ATP
c'est juste tu prends les 8 meilleurs à
la fin de la saison et puis c'est un
blessé ou un je sais pas quoi tu prends
le VM et voilà donc tu as au final les 8
meilleurs de l'année qui viennent
s'expliquer donc là si tu prends pas sur
une année tu prends sur deux ans peu
importe tu fais une moyenne mais ça a du
sens en fait parce qu'à la base c'est ce
que tu veux c'est que cette champion du
monde qui est censé être le numéro 1 ou
pas loin et que tu es le meilleur
possible en face
après bon je dois dire récemment c'est
pas trop mal passé parce que nepo là
numéro 3 mondial et sur ce qui joue
c'est plutôt une sorte de numéro 2 quoi
dans les temps à qui compte il est
vraiment là Magnus qui était numéro 1
champion pour très longtemps et là au
pire si je viens justement mais c'est
Dingler en face et qui est le seul mec a
plus de 2008 quoi donc finalement
sur leurs pieds avoir des matchs qui à
chaque fois était
était pas trop mal quoi sur le sur le
sur le papier pas forcément le contenu
mais
tu pouvais pas trop rêver mieux
donc
[Musique]
mais quoi qu'il en soit et bizarre après
de toute façon tu auras toujours enfin
c'est pas des tournois où ce sera des
mauvais qui gagne qui se qualifieront ça
c'est sûr aussi
dans la Coupe du monde pour faire 3e de
Coupe du Monde
oui
en général pas mal qui arrive là
quoi s'il y avait Carlson cette année
qui a perdu c'est ça et c'était qui de
l'autre côté
en dernière place enfin je veux dire de
base normalement je sais pas un mec que
je vois jouer les candidats mais si
c'est un gros tournoi comme ça c'est pas
un mec mauvais non plus à 2007 quoi donc
pourquoi pas en fait
non non clairement il y a le grand
suisse de toute façon c'est un tournoi
Suisse comme son nom l'indique et ce
sera les meilleurs mondiaux qui seront
dans les premiers
oui en plus il manquait beaucoup de noms
la dernière fois au grand Suisse et
c'est quand même il y avait que 4 on va
dire
qui sont passés donc si tu mets huit
têtes d'affiches tu en auras
probablement
sur les trois tu dois pas être loin
parce que ça se passe en Suisse le 26
c'est pas forcément et jusque là non
mais
ça pourrait
système
si je pouvais revenir je pense ce serait
normal le grand Suisse en Suisse en
Suisse quoi
en fait Suisse c'est le c'est un système
d'appariement de partie et donc le grand
Suisse c'est le grand tournoi système
suisse en réalité c'est un genre
d'abréviation
c'est comme si tu manges un Grec tu es
pas obligé d'aller en Grèce quoi
exactement
mais ça peut être pas mal de manger en
graissant un Grec en graisse quoi
est-ce que je suis prêt je suis pas trop
loin de Genève je suis Saint-Étienne
alors c'est pas à côté à côté mais bon
tu fais deux heures de route
mais ça peut ça peut tourner là il a
plus trop de temps
il a fait un peu de la merde non on
bouffe donc
tu as un genre de
bloque le roi
[Musique]
mérited
car aussi je te dis tout de suite
bah écoute c'est mieux que ce soit un
petit peu devant toi qui se prenne l'eau
quoi
qu'il change mais j'ai peur dans le
genre de position qui rentre dans le
dans la filière de Magnus quoi
il joue pas trop le cette année jusqu'à
maintenant c'est plutôt bien passé
passer dans le match toutes les
positions vont bien
donc on va voir comment il va comment il
va nous gérer ça
j'ai pas eu de bol à chaque fois c'est
55 ans le score pour sortir
7 matchs j'ai fait zéro sur 7
non mais bon
ça commence à faire une côte ou quoi
enfin genre c'est quand même beaucoup
de puissance 7 ça fait combien il y a
quelqu'un qui va me dire dans le chat
mais enfin ça fait beaucoup trop quoi
c'est vraiment du hasard en plus c'est
Fajr tu as pas de
de se faire c'est quand même
il y avait la Belgique il y avait plus
de chance d'être championne du monde que
ça m'arrive quoi enfin
tu vas la pensif
mais non ça va
c'est la balle perdue pour la Belgique
qui t'a fait mal
ouais non non
tu fais pas de tir au but
tu rajoutes encore 90 minutes en fait
mes limites tu pourrais en fait j'ai vu
un tweet plastique ça va en fait en
finale tu peux dire oui on fait un but
en or enfin vu tes problèmes et puis
après bah je vais jusqu'à épuisement
bah ouais mais en fait je trouverai ça
pas mal pour la finale ouais en fait
autant avant je comprends que tu peux
pas faire jouer une équipe pendant 8
heures et puis après ils tiennent plus
debout et bah tu peux pas le jeu de nage
après bah là démerdez-vous mais bon
après pourquoi pas les tireurs aussi
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas bête pour
une chaîne si il y a pas de thyroïde je
pense que si c'est range qui fait les
règles bon
enfin s'il va pas et ça va pas être
transmis de prolongation dans tous les
cas
ça va minimum être au moins une heure 50
de
1h45 de prolongation vraiment pour être
bien sûr
pour habbi Fabi je dis pas un but en or
tempo tu joues ta vraie prolongation
normale et c'est la 120e bah ça a pas
bougé ou que là il y a trois trois ou
peu importe bah ça continue avec un mur
en or alors
mais oui Rennes chez les mettrai pas de
but en or il dira ah ben une deuxième
prolongation de 30 minutes
au moins une heure
pas assez sûr
mais
en fait du coup c'est une question pas
idiote en fait j'en sais rien enfin je
sais pas trop quoi en penser mais ça
peut se réfléchir
tir au but en 20 tire ah bah oui ça
c'est beau aussi
mais je pense que on pouvait mettre
autant de tirs on pouvait mettre autant
de tir que tu veux de façon perdez les
tirs au but
on a un problème c'est que en fait le
risque est vraiment pas bon pour les
tirs au but
et le gouver l'argent pour le coup il
est pas mal
donc c'est un problème
alors ici il est vraiment pas fou
c'est comme ça en fait j'ai l'impression
que c'est hyper facile pour l'attaquant
de savoir de quel côté il saute ouais je
sais pas ce qu'il fait un truc qui va
pas il est presque un exercice très
spécial et puis le reste du jeu il est
rassurant il a fait une bonne Coupe du
Monde bon aujourd'hui je sais pas je
l'ai pas trouvé son assiette c'est
peut-être le
choc qui se prend au début du match ou
que je sais pas si c'était tous malade
avec le virus je veux pas trop te dire
mais je sais pas mais peu importe mais
mais oui pour être sûr de toute façon
c'est une constante c'est pas
aujourd'hui ou c'est tout le temps en
fait mais on est d'accord on est
d'accord que leur virus en fait c'est
juste le covid
probablement ils vont jamais communiquer
dessus donc
là le virus enfin je sais pas enfin ça
fait quand même trois ans qui fait que
de me parler de ça la tête
tu l'appelles plus du commissaire le
virus là je sais pas mais peut-être
c'est juste une sorte de communication
officielle parce que vu que nous simple
simplement si on a le si on est positif
on dirait de temps fermé que si que ça
là des mecs qui jouent une coupe du
monde c'est hyper médiatique et ils ont
le covid sur un terrain un moment tu vas
te dire c'est quoi ce de quoi de mesure
donc peut-être qu'ils peuvent pas dire
ça me rend fou en fait le virus est mort
en mode bon enfin tu as un nouveau virus
qui donne un peu de fièvre un peu mal à
la gorge voilà je sais pas c'est
complètement secret genre un truc bon
mais j'en sais rien en fait que là ils
étaient en forme ou quoi mais j'étais
vraiment l'impression qu'ils arrêtent
pas à courir quoi enfin dans tous les
impacts tous les duels ont été défoncés
en fait c'est un miracle de deux et que
après il y a eu 3 3 mais que ça pue je
des fois par intermittence c'est déjà
incroyable d'avoir fait douter
l'Argentine et de votre gagner
mais moi ça m'a donné l'impression que
c'était pas à 100%
mais bon ok ça tu vois jamais parce que
de toute façon tu communiques pas dessus
et puis c'est la vie c'est pas d'excuse
genre en 98 Ronaldo il était pas dans
son assiette non plus ça dans un sens
dans un autre et c'est comme ça quoi
donc
donc ok mais ouais ça m'a donné cette
impression en tout cas
mais oui
je crois que je l'ai vérité un penalty
dans toute ma vie
mais je crois que c'était contre les
Suisses là quand on était à zéro
et qu'il arrête un penalty puis après
puis on perd aussi au but déjà après il
en arrêt de plus et
mais ouais mais non pour le coup il est
pas mal tu reviens de toute façon il
était pas là il était pas dans le groupe
donc
quoi dire c'est comme ça
bon il a l'air de la tenir les carreaux
encore
pour l'instant ça va très bien après
faut avoir avec la pendule et demi de
moins donc peut-être que un moment ça va
s'activer vers la fin qu'on la partie
précédente en fait c'est bizarre mais
scénario de chaque partie c'est un peu
il se passe pas grand chose bien ils ont
plus de temps et ça s'anime sur la fin
son match Caro écoute il nous fait
mentir en tout cas pour le moment et
Magnus qui jouait vraiment bien après
sûr que Maggie il a regardé le foot à
fond
mais je pense pas que c'est un grand
impact pour le match non enfin bon
je sais pas pour qui il était d'ailleurs
mais peut-être que peut-être qu'il est
content ou peut-être pas enfin dur à
dire je sais pas
plutôt pour la France je pense
parce qu'il est pour le Real
du coup je pense ça doit te saouler que
mes 6 gagnent une coupe du monde c'est
connoté Barça
et en plus
il y a il va sûrement partir au Real
quand même un de ces quatre
donc tu es un peu il devait quand même
plutôt être pour la France
mais en fait je crois que la planète
entière était plutôt pour l'Argentine il
y a que nous en France bon bah nous
c'est normal mais
globalement tout le monde est plutôt
content pour Messi en fait ce qui
s'entend
c'est cool pour lui et puis bon bah du
coup tu es content pour pas redesc aussi
quoi par ricochet non mais moi je suis
pas fou
mais
[Musique]
bon comme dit je peux pas dire que soit
pas mérité sur le sur l'ensemble du
match
c'est joli dame B2 du coup si tu prends
tout en dessin quand même il y a tort C8
maths
le coup d'avant il a fait Gifi pour ça
et ça recommence bien joué
du coup maintenant il a son pion dépassé
qu'on n'arrive pas à bouffer et la
structure du coup est bien c'est toi les
Noirs ils ont baissé
et voilà
elle a tout Rambo 5 elle va être belle
en plus
elle va tout bloquer
à devoir qui perdait pas le pion des
bien joué
normalement c'est un meilleur joueur
mais après il Caro
tac tac tac il est là quoi c'est un
poseur de barbelé en fait
je crois que je suis attendu ça une
belle c'est pas la meilleure équipe
qu'il remportait je suis à terre
je lisais le chat
[Musique]
bien joué parce que ça tape
directement sur le roi
il en a besoin
et ça suit côté macdouche
il va pas être bien si gagne pas quand
même
comment ça va faire beaucoup
ouais c'est l'inverse du match de Maxime
en fait contre Maxime il était plutôt
légèrement dominé dans certaines parties
mais bon attention
[Musique]
ok
les noirs
pas trop compte mais oui
bon c'est rien
ok c'est quand même un petit plus ouais
non c'est rien je sais pas comment on
peut faire quoi alors là tu peux rien
faire
tu peux comprendre qui doit pas être
trop content de lui a vu la belle
position qu'il avait et puis c'est la
deuxième qui rate quand même
parce qu'avec les blancs là dans l'Est
indienne il avait été bien aussi il
était très bien et puis je dois dire
c'est le petit père avant il est pas
obligé
qu'est-ce qui nous joue là
je connais pas du tout ce qui m'a fait
réussisse en fait c'est un mystique
il fait une tête un peu bizarre
OK
dans son malheur c'est pas trop grave
enfin si jamais ça je pense que mais bon
c'est un genre de Gambie de Budapest
nous t'as mis le confiant qui est ouais
je sais pas c'est pas si clair
en tout cas Hikaru il peut pas être sûr
que c'est du misclick
bah il suit en fait Ikao
ouais bon écoute tu rock tu mets tes
tours ta petite caisse des 5 peut-être
un jour pour un cavale
[Musique]
tu fais kevaler eux
projet 2 je voulais prendre du Caval et
rebondir en F4 et vers dessin ou truc
comme ça quoi
c'est bien joué
tu casses un peu la structure
OK
pas clair cette position
l'ordi donne un avantage au blanc mais
franchement pour moi il est pas évident
non bon structure bon ok
non c'est pas trop clair
c'est plutôt mieux blanc mais c'est vrai
que l'ordi ils sont belles peut-être un
peu
plus sain c'est quand même énorme par
rapport au à ce que je vois bon ok tu
dirais plus 0,3 je te dis pourquoi pas
mais plus un
normalement il y a un truc concret
d'ailleurs
un truc concret peut-être en fait
pourquoi pas ça va monter descendre
c'est bien ça fait un peu d'animation
sur le live en fait
OK
au bout d'un moment
je sais pas trop à quoi il réfléchit ce
qui regarde toute la fois si c'est
bizarre quand même
à 4 bêtements donc je sais pas ouais
juste bien logique
pourquoi bizarre parfois c'est bizarre
tu t'en vas de la diagonale tu laisses
le tatouage à 8 tu te coupes ton gâteau
prends un 4 alors après je comprends les
deux mais
ça a l'air d'être hyper artificiel quoi
après bon ça se trouve ça va mais il y a
même temps
franchement c'est trop chez Ikea
donc ça a l'air beaucoup logique on
développe la dernière pièce pas
développée on la ramène vers B6 verset 5
pour défendre l'option A4 au cas où on
améliore les pièces on lit les tours
enfin ça se respecte bien les principes
qui donc ça tout pour être un coup
correct a priori c'est normal quoi
si Magnus plomb autant je sais pas il y
a un truc à regarder très concret que je
vois ça je vois pas ce qui regarde en
fait c'est ça qui est qui m'étonne
un coup simple à jouer avec la main
après si voilà ils font plus rien avec
les mains
4 ou 2 tome 2 x 2 tu reprends à 8 ans
quand même attention
ta machine 06 faudrait pas donner des
tours en un
il arrive combien de temps au final
deux minutes 25 ok c'est beaucoup
en fait qui faisait une double attaque
tu auras des tours en deux
ok c'est compliqué je comprends l'ordi
il faut faire j'ai 5 menaces maths quoi
c'est un thème classique c'est qui est
G5 position après faut l'évaluer
des trucs sur B2 c'est compliqué
mais ouais ouais enfin c'est quand même
après
je me disais aussi
c'est complexe
quand même puis tu veux tourbéciste et
puis voilà
mais ça peut lui faire mal en fait si le
mené deux points autoproclamé meilleur
genre de Blitz du monde en fait Magnus
peut-être
bah écoute les poissons
mais contre les vannes oui c'était pas
100% qui était là avant le match contre
les vannes je ne suis qu'à 1% de ma
force
et c'est vraiment
freezer en fait
je peux encore avoir 10 transformations
mais celle-ci est sur très heureux
un tel con toi tu crois
j'ai quel âge j'ai bientôt 39 ans
d'où une connaissance poussée de Dragon
Ball
toute toute ma jeunesse
est blanc on suit dans le sens
l'échiquier dans le bon sens quoi
jusqu'à maintenant
le truc c'est quoi il est très réaliste
dire que enfin on va attendre qu'il
gagne on va pas lui porter la poisse on
va dire mais ok quand c'est une occasion
il l'a gagné pour l'instant là il est en
train de faire le taf on va dire et les
deux parties étaient plutôt mal mais il
a pas perdu
exactement
il met les buts quand il a les occases
mais les barbels
il bloque la case tu le poses quand tu
veux ou tu dois à chaque coup tu le
changes de place
exactement et ça fait trois pour Hikaru
il est pas bien Magnus non
il doit suer
mais c'est mort enfin Mathieu m'a
expliqué un jeu avec lequel ils ont en
Belgique et ça se trouve c'est le jeu du
canard en fait j'aime bien en fait bon
c'est les Belges il pose une bière genre
en E5 on va dire et c'est au blanc et
genre tu as peur de jouer au Cap déjà tu
enverrai la pièce la bière en 7 donc
peut-être tu peux faire E3 ou je sais
pas quoi et ça décale
et puis les Noirs rejouent par exemple
ils font des cinq la bière repart en 4
etc quoi la pierre est décalée du
[Musique]
premier coup en fait ok donc tu as le
droit de jouer des quatre comme ça la
bière
si tu fais cavalier F3 la bière irait en
D6
etc et voilà et donc la terrasse
peut-être faire intercepter la bière que
par exemple c'est énorme ou un pion en
dessin qui est une dame en D8 tu joues
un coup qui va envoyer la bière en
décide c'est le pire des cinq et puis
défendu quoi etc quoi
jamais jouer de Coulomb parce qu'en fait
tu ferais sortir la bière de l'échiquier
tu n'as pas loin c'est hyper chaud
on a parlé comme ça je trouve ça marrant
mais donc c'est pas tout à fait ça le
joli canard non j'ai du canard le canard
obstrue une case en fait
ok tu prends le canard et tu déplaces le
canard pour qu'il obstrue une case bon
tu peux pas passer dessus et c'est un
fou il peut pas mais genre je veux dire
là il y aura un canard en dessin la
toile peut coller en 17
ils font déjà une pause là ah bah oui
oui c'est la pause c'est la mi-temps de
la première période c'est les nouvelles
postes qui étaient introduites cette
année qui font très plaisir
on va pas le temps passer là les gars
il y a une pause à la moitié des en fait
c'est un peu comme ce foot avait une
mi-temps à 22 minutes la pause fraîcheur
quand même ouais c'est ça
moi je suis vraiment fan des pauses
cab le jeu du canard de chasse
ok bon
pourquoi pas
à devenir très fort à Dieu du canard
façon tu joues un peu à tous les jeux à
la con
ouais mais pas beaucoup
Eric Rozen et Caro ils ont joué ouais
c'est pour dire à quel point c'est un
jeu de génie
non mais pourquoi pas on pourrait
essayer
après je sais pas pourquoi ils ont pas
mis la dame cachée
il y a d'autres règles un peu spéciales
tu peux te mettre en échec et bloquer
avec le canard ah bah ouais mais le
canard il fait tout quoi
mais ouais la dame cachée c'est un très
beau jeu
bah ouais c'est magnifique une sorte de
bluff dedans et tout
c'est bien parce qu'il va rester que en
gros 40 minutes de jeu
et après tu aurais une nouvelle pause
ouais c'est beau jeu les quatre et les
échecs à 4 tu as pas trop jouer non
mais le Fox a joué contre qui qui ont
des gens que tu connais ou tu
es le brouillard là
ouais ouais je crois que tu peux bouffer
loin je sais plus en fait un moment que
j'ai pas joué mais
et voilà quoi
et donc ouais le but c'est de contrôler
un peu un peu de terrain
et tu dois quoi
est-ce que je vais faire un match de
chasse boxing
je connais des gens qui sont allés
d'ailleurs en réel
allez voir ouais
et qui m'ont écrit que c'était très bœuf
bah je sais pas moi j'ai pas regardé
donc je peux pas dire
moi j'ai regardé ça a pas trop pu et
j'ai des gens que je connais bien qui
sont allés ils étaient plusieurs en plus
et ils ont tous trouvé que c'était pas
terrible
en fait je crois que fondamentalement je
suis pas trop fan du jazz boxing mais
que bon je peux comprendre l'idée et je
sais pas mais
donc il faudrait que j'insiste en vrai
une fois pour avoir un avis un vrai et
voilà non mais là en fait c'est pas
vraiment compte le chat boxing qu'ils
étaient contre c'est juste qu'ils
étaient les combats étaient claqués au
sol en fait c'est aucun intérêt en fait
donc oui ça remettait pas c'était pas en
mode oui le chasboxing c'est nul ou quoi
c'était pas du tout
je trouve pas un grand intérêt à la
compétition en soi je veux dire mais
mais oui du coup je comprends bien que
c'est les combats de boxe sont pas cool
en plus alors tu viens quand même voir
ça
alors tu viens plus voir les mecs faire
un beau combat de boxe un peu se mettre
sur la tronche que regarder leur coup
d'échecs
ouais ouais mais ça manque de boxeurs
professionnels
professionnel contre un
de nous on va prendre cher quoi et très
vite
allez compétitions de claques ouais tu
as déjà vu ça
c'est extraordinaire
qu'on tombe chaos déjà mais ils ont une
belle résistance puis ils envoient et
c'est très beau sport c'est les roses
sont très forts
je vois bien carpac chef je vois ça moi
ça reparti vous avez vu la box dans une
cabine téléphonique ouais je crois aussi
c'est les roues coffres qui ont inventé
ce sport
exceptionnel
dans une petite cavité téléphonique et
se mettre sur la gueule
c'est bravo quoi
ok donc Magnus qui a changé de premier
coup qui part sur le 4e
maintenant est-ce qu'il vaut mieux deux
boxeurs pro qui savent pas jouer aux
échecs ou deux joueurs d'échec pro qui
savent pas boxer en fait moi je pars du
principe que quand les gens font des
erreurs aux échecs c'est drôle et c'est
facile à expliquer donc les échecs en
fait c'est un des rares jeux où tu as
pas besoin que les mecs soient vraiment
bons pour kiffer
et la boxe en fait c'est l'inverse c'est
que si les mecs ne savent pas boxer
c'est assez chiant à regarder en fait ça
n'a pas grand intérêt donc c'est plus
logique de mettre des gens qui box ce
bien enfin pour moi
et qui joue mal aux échecs parce que du
coup ben voilà alors que l'inverse en
fait ce que l'inverse tu souffres
je vais aussi dans l'autre sens au pire
ça serait genre une seule battle quand
c'est des humil ou quoi mais qui se boxe
bien donc en fait ils vont souvent les
parties en plus en 8000 on les voit
elles sont palpitantes parce qu'il y a
des hauts débats tu sais pas trop ce qui
se passe
et ça finit rarement très vite si ils
prennent pas des maths du berger non
plus en fait
donc en fait ça finit aussi à la fin
c'est dure longtemps tu sais pas trop
c'est très indécis et donc tu as la box
tu peux avoir ton explication à la box
et
je sais pas c'est plus logique parce que
c'est que le mec qui joue bien aux échec
en fait juste être contre un vrai boxeur
bon il va juste mourir en fait c'est
enfin ou l'arbitre je pense que même pas
commencer le combat c'est trop dangereux
donc là en fait du coup c'est logique ce
qui tape enfin je sais pas c'est normal
que dans un confrontation c'est pas le
plus intelligent qui gagne quoi
tu peux rien intelligence de boxe mais
oui non mais en fait c'est normal enfin
entre eux normalement c'est un jeu où
c'est plus important de se faire à la
boxe quoi
non mais je sais pas c'est entre
Einstein un mec tu tapes sur la gueule
ferme ta gueule
non enfin je sais pas c'est plus je
trouve ça logique en fait
non mais oui ça marche plus comme ça
c'est ce que tu dis de m'intéresse pas
donc tiens regarde
plus fort que toi
j'ai levé le débat quoi donc
c'est beau
donc en fait dans ce sens là sport
semble plus logique
bon en tout cas ça a l'air d'être assez
égal encore comme position même si les
Blancs ont peut-être un petit
chewing à plus agréable mais bon on va
voir s'il arrive
un truc dans la position
sortir le foot case noir je veux la case
5 les grands classiques de la française
des changent même si c'est ça passe par
une autre ouverture c'est la même
structure
assez heureux quand même
mais je pense qu'il va être très heureux
si il gagne
enfin c'est fou à quel point ils sont
quand même plus fort les deux
c'est clair en fait la finale c'est
normal en fait
ils ont gagné tous les deux tous leurs
matchs quand même relativement
facilement même si ça réuni c'est un peu
accroché je dirais rien de
enfin tu sens que c'était en maîtrise
côté
Ikaru et Magnus il a il a écrasé tout le
monde en fait
en soi Maximilien fait un super match
mais il perd quand même 17 à 9 enfin
Magnus a l'air très zen on nous dit
ouais après
il joue pas ça mais bon je pense qu'il a
envie de gagner parce que il a
il a
mais c'était Go et en plus il carou
c'est un peu son
[Musique]
ennemi ces ils ont une rivalité voilà
donc il a envie d'y aller pour conserver
son son avantage contre Caro ou en
général il le bat quasi toujours en tout
cas dans les matchs les trucs comme ça
donc voilà mais après en soit c'est pas
voilà c'est pas un type de champion du
monde non plus en jeu quoi
oui pour lui c'est je pense que le
championnat du monde de Blitz c'est
rapide est plus important pour tout le
monde qui va avoir lieu là dans quelques
jours maintenant simplement parce que ça
commence le 26 donc c'est dans huit
jours
ça ce sera vraiment le gros le gros
rendez vous de cette fin d'année on en
parlait avec message privé en discutant
un petit peu avec Maxime et oui il lui
aussi il voyait plus le speechers comme
une préparation pour voir où il en était
pour cet échéance quoi
qui est quand même un gros échéance de
fin d'année forcément
mais d'un autre côté Magnus bah
maintenant qu'il a plus le titre de
champion du monde en classique à
défendre etc il a quand même envie sur
des des compétitions comme ça de montrer
qu'il est le plus fort quoi parce qu'en
plus c'est des formes où tu vois quand
même vraiment enfin
il y a vraiment peu dedans comme là un
match de foot réellement tu rajouterais
400 minutes de match sur sur deux mois
quoi
pour vraiment voir qui est le plus fort
c'est-à-dire que là c'est speechess
c'est le temps de jeu est quand même
extrêmement long donc si tu gagnes un
match comme ça c'est quand même dire que
tu es plus fort quoi en train avec moi
enfin en tout cas aujourd'hui
peu de place à l'aléatoire au final
je sais pas ce que tu en penses Fab
mais ouais non oui je pense
effectivement
il préférerait un titre de champion du
monde de [ __ ] ou de rapide la semaine
prochaine mais bon disons là n'empêche
pas l'autre il a le droit de gagner
aujourd'hui et d'être double champion du
monde dans une semaine aussi quoi
en tout cas c'est la première fois que
je le vois être quand même plutôt dominé
par Icare bon j'ai jamais vu dominer
comme ça non je suis d'accord
il y a déjà perdu des parties bien sûr
mais là ça commence à faire quoi quatre
parties jouées
5e
[Musique]
truc évidemment une gaffe peut arriver
ou quoi mais la position elle tient bien
pour les carreaux là il y a pas de grand
danger
tension quand même hein parce que sur
cavalier enfin si tu arrives avec
cavalier F5 dam G4 tu menaceras et dame
ranger 7 et cavalier H6
bien joué G6
tu peux travailler sur des détails des
trucs
ouais tu progresses toujours en réalité
ou pas d'ailleurs mais tu peux
régresses sur ta vitesse de calcul sur
le cognitif intrinsèque mais tu
progresses sur le jeu quoi tu vois plus
de connaissances élargir ta palette dans
les ouvertures
travailler quelque chose enfin genre
quand on paraît-il un petit point de
faible sur les finales bah là il a
beaucoup travaillé les finales du coup
donc voilà même un gars qui a 2008 il
peut encore progresser
et puis pour parler d'autres sports
comme je sais pas en tennis comme Nadal
qui au fur et à mesure de sa carrière
améliorer son revers améliorer son
service alors qu'il y ait des années à
la base quoi
donc c'est important
après tu vois un sport où tu vois pas
trop les joueurs progresser ou c'est
plus des des séquences de forme je
trouve ce rugby
les joueurs progressent aussi mais c'est
plus rare tu as plus de joueurs qui font
des coups d'éclats genre tu les vois ils
jouent bien pendant une saison ou quoi
et après il regresse et c'est vraiment
que les top top joueurs qui réussissent
à progresser j'ai l'impression que c'est
un sport ou c'est vraiment difficile de
progresser
au moins dans le jeu au pied ou
certaines phases de jeux particulières
j'ai l'impression que c'est dur
mais après ouais c'est très physique
c'est vrai qu'il y a des gars qui
peuvent rayonner tu as raison puis d'un
coup ils ont le coup de mou et tu
deviens un joueur un peu lambda l'année
d'après ouais mais tu as même parfois
des piliers ou quoi en début de saison
pendant deux trois mois ils sont en
pleine bourdes à l'impression que les
mecs ils sont inarrêtables genre
implacables
et après tu la revois un peu en fin de
saison bon ils sont très moyens la
saison d'après ils sont rentrés dans le
rang et ça arrive hyper souvent des
joueurs genre qui rentrent dans le rang
et c'est vraiment que les meilleurs ceux
qui sont en équipe de France les
internationaux et tout qui tout au long
de leur carrière ils ont une régularité
de génie on va dire
des autres en fait c'est à dire qu'il se
passe pas grand chose et on arrive là
ils ont moins de 30 secondes ça va
s'animer mais cargo défense super bien
ok
on va venir en D6 pour aller peut-être
vers 4 ou quoi puis avoir tout revu qui
arrive quoi
d'ailleurs
c'est un grand mot mais c'est les noirs
qui ont le bon fou finalement
4 ouais enfin c'est oui oui enfin c'est
pas si simple pour ma douche oui en fait
c'est pas Magnus Carlson c'est Mac
mouche mars
en fait il y a eu un changement de McDo
[Musique]
il arrive pas à trouver le lien
il aurait pu la jouer un petit peu
mieux mais bon après il est en gestion
aussi très frappe pas trop gérer contre
Magnus il faut prendre les points quand
l'opportunité
on dit la valeur tellement fort Magnus
contre Maxime pourtant ah ouais mais il
Caro quand il est vraiment en forme
c'est quand même un sacré morceau on se
rappelle que l'année où Maxime avait
battu Magnus il avait pris très très
cher en finale après un
je me rappelle plus du score exact mais
il a été pris peut-être pris 7 8 points
d'écart enfin il s'est fait marcher
dessus en fait
donc il est en forme
il est complexe à jouer mais après on se
rappelle aussi que Maxime l'an dernier
qui avait été catastrophique au speed
chasse contre karwana il avait
d'ailleurs perdu le match un mois après
il était champion du monde d'échec donc
au bout d'un moment enfin bon oui
ça c'est une soirée
[Musique]
disons que à cette
à cette cadence
avec ce format c'est clairement les deux
meilleures en tout cas ouais c'est sûr
on nous dit c'était serré jusqu'au
Bullet Maxime était même passé devant
non j'avais commenté le match c'était
pas serré
juste pour un point de détail
normalement en fait le fou d'étrangles
fait que le Cayen géant pour jouer des
idées qui a lieu deux et G3 d'ailleurs
s'appelle avant de sert à one
antidote c'est de faire très vite pour
faire pression sur le pion des cas je
sens que le fond interfère etc et là en
fait je vais essayer F3 normal et tu
mets le fond en Détroit donc toujours
pas le plan normal mais
[Musique]
mais bon voilà c'était juste ça qui est
un peu étonnant dans cette nouvelle
manière de jouer alors attends ils
disent que le match était serré je vais
regarder je confonds peut-être avec un
autre match parce qu'il y en a eu
plusieurs des matchs de Maxime qui ont
tricaru il y en a un qui était vraiment
pas assez du tout mais c'est peut-être
pas celui de l'an dernier je vais aller
vérifier je suis curieux
il y a 2 ans
l'an dernier l'an dernier c'était contre
karwana et c'était très serré mais
compris Caro
normalement en fait maxime est bien plus
fort que Fabiano dans ce format et
d'ailleurs on a vu comment
minus a gagné facilement quoi contre
Fabiano et donc le match soit serré
c'est déjà un peu une contre-performance
et en plus perdre ça c'était vraiment
étonnant c'est quelle année du coup ce
truc mais c'est il y a longtemps en fait
je pense c'est peut-être 2019 ou 18 ou
pas 2020 je pense pas je pense pas que
ça donne je pense c'est 2019 enfin la
finale qui est le contre les carreaux
de mémoire
j'étais à Paris en commentaire
[Musique]
j'étais à Paris l'année covid mais
2020 c'est peut-être 2020 quand même
c'est décembre 2020 alors si c'est
pas si c'est ça c'est ça
je suis en train de chercher
ça c'est une bonne chose
[Musique]
mais bon c'est pas spécialement serré
comme match en plus ça finit sur quel
score
ouais sa fille sur 17 à 12
et nakamé avant les bullets ouais quand
même
c'était plus sec avec ce que je pensais
c'est le match qui était moins serré
mais peu importe
non on m'a pas perdu vous inquiétez pas
les gars
c'est juste disait rien là
c'est bon ils ont changé d'avis c'est
juste je parlais pas en fait
je te laissais parce qu'en fait moi je
voyais pas les scores donc je les ai dit
le contenu du match et tout ça quoi
ouais c'était le match d'avant mais bon
en tout cas il Caro qui domine
tout le monde
puis là il y a encore pas trop mal quoi
je pense qu'il peut prendre ce fou quand
même
du coup en prenant le foot ça peut
donner F4
et tu allais te prendre des à trois et
des problèmes sur la grande diagonale là
maintenant tu peux probablement y aller
hein
je pense qu'il est déjà plus grand donc
il fait quoi il fait 1m90 quasi
mais il est plus grand il est plus grand
que Messi attention c'est oui question
un peu bizarre
parce que Messi peut grandir encore ou
pas un 60
c'était pas spécifié hein
nous on est très premier degré ici
par les grands nommé je pense si parler
en termes renommé il aurait mis hein il
a vraiment écrit texto est-ce qu'il est
plus grand ouais non c'était ça parlait
taille
après en terme de renommée je sais pas
c'est toujours dur
s'il y a plusieurs grandes singes je
sais pas j'ai pas envie de classer des
mecs individuellement sur des sports
collectifs dans l'histoire tu as plein
de grands joueurs on s'en souvient
encore des décennies après mais si on va
pas l'oublier
même si Mbappé devient plus grand joueur
le meilleur joueur du monde pendant un
moment qui va dominer ou pas enfin on
verra comment ça se passe
mais si ce qu'il aura fait ça reste un
délibile quoi
il a l'air tellement bien Hikaru
en dessin et puis tu vas pouvoir viser
la case F6 en fait il le défonce mais
genre il y a une énorme différence de
niveau entre les deux je suis personne
ne doit pas être trop dedans parce que
c'est pas le problème les joues très
bien mais que Magnus passe dominer comme
ça j'ai jamais vu de ma vie en fait bah
il est peut-être juste moins fort
maintenant il a peut-être régressé
et c'est vraiment dominé assez sèchement
hyper concentré dans son match
il faut l'être
non
finale ce sera un bel accomplissement
et surtout que là il le bat pas en
belette
bon c'est pas encore complètement fait
on voit la jauge qui repasse
en partie lente tu peux trouver des
ressources mais là
faites un pion de moins déjà bon c'est
déjà c'est ça et a priori faiblesses sur
15 ans quoi alors après peut-être tu
auras un contre jeu une tactique sur B2
un machin un moment mais on le voit pas
arriver comme ça c'est dur d'aller
réattaquer plus en fait t'as pas la
caisse C4 pour l'instant pour le
cavalier il y a pas de dames
tomber 5 intermédiaire
il a l'air très heureux
quand même il a pas été bien quand il
lui a joué
bim
il voulait plus voir des misères c'est
bien joué le tour des un
ça c'est tombé
ça fait beaucoup de tomber quand même
enfin
c'est le troisième c'est le troisième
tombée déjà
après il tombe pas dans les positions il
est mieux non plus
écoute ça commence à faire long là le
score c'est
ok bon ben on n'a pas vu venir scénario
de match après il a peut-être le virus
bah peut-être parce qu'il a enfin en
fait moi je dois dire que quand je tombe
comme une merde comme ça c'est souvent
que je suis malade
mais après je sais pas lui je sais pour
moi souvent c'est une des conséquences
je contrôle plus du tout le temps
peut-être qu'il est bourré ouais c'est
possible aussi
une sur la France et il suit
je pense qu'il en reste un peu pour
assumer son pari si jamais
on dirait quand tu es malade tu mets
plus longtemps réfléchir ouais c'est
pour ça moi je sais quand je suis malade
je tombe nettement plus souvent c'est
incroyable
mais ouais non c'est c'est étonnant
après
j'ai juste l'impression qu'il est moins
fort et puis c'est tout hein
il a pas l'air d'être bien et il Caro là
c'est en train de le faire marrer il a
l'air d'être tellement heureux et il
commence à danser à ses Terri il
commence à être insupportable attention
tu as tué la peau du saumon
il est en train de les cailler Fab
mais après ouais peut-être peut-être
petit erreur de Magnus qui a mis un pull
vert là c'est pas forcément la bonne
couleur Fab plus
de d'autres couleurs qui marchent mieux
ok oui
je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça la
décision à prendre
sa péchoir bon côté Nakamura nous dit
sourire
et le harpon il le sort pas que pour
pêcher
ils sont plus ouverts et vraiment
horrible en plus
et Caro et tout sourire et tellement
heureux
il fait des petits sourires à la caméra
on dirait un pulse Subway nous dit-on
dans le chaton sont plus là c'est moches
je dois dire après peut-être c'est sur
la caméra que le verre en pas forcément
bien c'est une couleur quand même
difficile
des fois avec le contraste ça peut
c'est dur c'est dur Fab
voilà il a joué quelques bons coups non
Magnus
place
mais voilà rien de faire c'est toujours
très équilibré comme position et ça doit
aller carreaux que ça prenne du temps et
voilà
souvent des rêves où je foudra Magnus et
je deviens un champion du monde ça t'est
déjà arrivé non pas du tout
est très heureux là il se concentra à
fond il fait des grimaces à fond
c'est le même Magnus que contre Fabi et
Maxime bah contre Maxime je dois dire
que Max enfin on a trouvé qui défendait
très très bien Magnus mais si Maxime
avait conclu les parties le scénario du
match aurait été différent là peut-être
jusque Hikaru il est très légèrement
plus fort que Maxime mais que ça fait
fin en fait ça change beaucoup de choses
c'est un moment donné au lieu de sur les
cinq six parties que maxi m'a dominer il
a dû faire deux sur 6 à un moment donné
celui de faire de ces six si tu fais
cinq et demi sur 6 c'est peut-être pas
le même match non plus après
tu fais douter l'adversaire tu changes
la dynamique tu changes tout
c'est
pas pareil et oui
donc
en fait
c'est de toute façon c'est comme ça dans
les matchs en général
le réalisme je veux dire c'est un truc à
la con on parle de tous les sports mais
genre je souvent dans les matchs de
championnats du monde en a moins vu
récemment mais c'est le gars qui
défendait ses positions à la con qui
partaient pas
mais genre même le cramique kasparoff en
fait il a eu des finales difficiles à
défendre chronique un peu les a toutes
tenues il a pas perdu une seule partie
et lui il a frapper mais il est devenu
champion du monde quoi et il y a souvent
eu de ça en fait à travers l'histoire et
que c'était important quand tu as
l'opportunité tu dois tu dois gagner
parce qu'en plus ça compte double c'est
même pas comme un open c'est que tu
gagnes et ton adversaire quoi enfin tu
fais tu fais vraiment un gros écart
pas plus loin que les candidats aussi
regardez pas finalement
il gagne large mais en fait je veux dire
par là il a parti qui joue contre icaru
car où il est gagnant il bat des pots
[Musique]
au début c'est position ben du coup il
fait ouais c'est souvent celui qui sauve
en fait d'aller arracher ses demi points
là et donc encore plus dans les face à
face évidemment mais ça fait une énorme
différence quoi et là en fait mainus bah
il a eu plusieurs positions il était
plutôt bien genre même celle-là d'être
typée de pousser ou quoi et en fait si
tu gagnes pas
[Musique]
dans le sport le réalisme
d'ailleurs tu vois même quand tu passes
de Ligue 2 en Ligue 1 ils te dis souvent
la différence une équipe de Ligue 1 il
te punit quoi
fais plein de choses
c'est pas le même le même type de
réalisme mais plus tu montes les
échelons de chaque sport plus les gens
font tout mieux mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est les c'est surtout les zones
décisives en fait qui font des
différences après
exactement pareil pour ce speech Maxime
qui était pas si loin et du coup
c'est très loin et très proche à la fois
peut-être qu'il fait un tout petit peu
ce que fait Maxime très légèrement mieux
et en plus Magnus c'est un joueur moi
j'en avais beaucoup parlé pendant le
match contre Maxime c'était 4 jours
c'était mercredi soir
j'avais beaucoup parlé du fait que
Magnus est un joueur qu'on pouvait faire
tilter et que si Maxime avait réussi à
gagner ses parties le match aurait été
bien différent parce que ça aurait
changé la dynamique de jeu et c'est un
peu ce qui se passe ce soir
ça peut vite tourner ça
je crois que c'est fini bah là il fait
des yathansaki ça y est il regarde hyper
bizarrement il fait 4 là il fait 40
millions de grimaces genre en mode
est-ce que Carlson est complètement con
oh mais c'est terrible en fait oh il se
fout de sa gueule je te jure il est en
train de se [ __ ] de sa gueule de
regarder de reculer de l'écran genre
mais il est complètement nul et ça il
refait encore une grimace genre en mode
est-ce que le mec il va être mon con
ouais ça y est il hallucine genre j'ai
rarement ouais mais c'est il fait
vraiment une tête genre j'ai rarement vu
un mec aussi nul de ma vie c'est
terrible il se fout de sa gueule
littéralement au premier degré oh les
grimaces qu'il est en train de lui faire
genre en mode mais ce qui s'est joué
quoi
oh il est en train
là en gros ce qui vient de faire c'est
enfin là il vient juste de l'humilier
avec Kadri masque quoi c'est
exceptionnel
ça c'est vraiment genre en mode c'est
quoi c'est parti pédagogiques qui ont
des 1200 ou c'est champion du monde en
face
là ça fait mal
4 points d'avance ouais on imagine le
scénario inverse en fait là
ouais mais c'est vraiment l'équivalent
là et enfin lave réellement il sait il a
juste humilié en fait c'est foutu de sa
gueule en fait
mais le premier degrés ouais tu es une
merde toi tu sais pas jouer connard
enfin c'est l'équivalent de ça ce qu'il
a fait en fait
[Musique]
s'enchaînent donc quand tu es sous l'eau
tu es sous l'eau quoi tu as pas le temps
de prendre ta petite bouffée d'oxygène
tu es
avec t'imagines tu as pas redesc en face
à tes carreau je pense que tu te fais
découper quand même par contre tu dois
pas être bien là
ça change quand même un peu des matchs
de rugby je te cache pas
c'est un peu regarder la Coupe d'Europe
ce weekend ouais tu fais ça ça va pas
bien se passer
ça va pas bien se passer du tout en fait
ah ouais mais là est-ce qu'il voit la
cam de l'autre ouais s'ils veulent ils
peuvent voir ça c'est ça
tout le temps c'est pas c'était pas
spécialement destiné Magnus
je pense tu fais ça en ce match de rugby
tu peux te prendre un plaquage
cathédrale à l'action d'après en fait
même si ça fait carton rouge c'est pas
grave tu auras plus de nuque
mais là clairement ouais c'est c'est
l'humiliada pour Carlsen
ouais c'est la branlade
bon après le truc c'est que de toute
façon
le rendez-vous qui sera pris il sera au
Kazakhstan non d'une semaine
c'est là que tout va se jouer mais c'est
quand même un
résultat qui fera date si carouille
Millie autant Carlsen que ça
en tout cas on s'attendait vraiment pas
à ce type de scénario Fab
pas du tout
après les démonstrations de Carlsen
contre carwana et contre
Maxime on le voyait quand même au-dessus
de ça en fait il perdait presque pas
enfin un compteur
2 2 3 maxi quoi
ouais maxime a raté il a eu beaucoup de
position quand même oui mais au final tu
vois alors que là il en a déjà perdu 4
il en a perdu plus là en un segment de
jeu que dans deux matchs cumulés ah oui
oui clairement et en comptant les
bullettes parce que joueur de belette
avant tout
sera du 26 au 28 décembre et le
championnat du monde de Blitz du 29 au
ça joue pas le 31 c'est que deux jours
c'est que deux jours OK
à demain
c'est très probable je pense l'an
dernier c'était comme ça en fait parce
que j'étais venu chez toi et je faisais
la route et j'étais pas venu le 31 pile
poil donc je t'ai mis la veille et quand
j'étais arrivé c'était les départages
contre Douda
exactement
on avait fait un bel nouvel an après
tu fais quoi cette année nous allons je
crois que je serai en Espagne
je vais jouer un tournoi du 26 au 30
alors que donc c'est un petit Blatt
c'est dans le sud et puis ça finit le 30
donc je vais rester et je serai avec
Axel de l'Orne et en fait on a pour
projet alors bon on va voir si on peut
trouver des places il va y avoir un
match le 31 de foot entre Villarreal et
Valence donc c'est le derby de entre
là-bas et on voulait aller au stade
sympa et voilà puis après c'est le 31 et
puis bien rentré donc voilà ça c'est le
plan après encore faut-il avoir des
places là on en a pas trouvé
et bah s'il y a pas de place on fera
autre chose mais voilà alors que c'est
la fin de la séquence 5 plus infa il y a
une petite sonnette donc ce sera la
dernière partie avant la pause et il
caroube qui a l'air d'être bien une
nouvelle voix
j'ai pas trop aimé le grand des Noirs en
fait
après je sais pas un peu ça pas si mal
mais
il va faire tout rache1 je pense
peut-être même
et après à 3 B4
c'est pénible pour cette dame qui a pas
trop de cases la caisse de 5 normalement
elle est pas trop mal pour la dame mais
est-ce que un petit coup de dames 3 sera
pas un souci
et du coup en fait la dame noire un peu
les trois alors peut-être faudra bouger
la piquette direct à cette tête très
bien joué dans 3 il a l'air hyper
heureux là
et il vient de faire de la cam oh le
malaise il fait des clins
de toute façon faut le prendre ce truc
mais oui il veut faire quoi
c'est la merde donc à trois fois aller
en C5 et il veut qu'il y ait des cinq
jeunes
alors faut aller danser 4
désolé fan je m'en remets pas bref
[Musique]
que tu sacrifies Adam compte de pièces
ou tu pars à 4 qui prend le 7 et tu es
un peu fermé mais je sais pas enfin bref
je vois pas trop les défenses en fait
à la cam il fait mal quand même
après faut pas trop en faire non plus
hein
contre un champion du monde comme ça
attends qui est dessiné peut-être
[Musique]
attention il a trop fait le malin là il
va peut-être être puni par les dieux des
échecs attention Fab
il puisse pas trop le dire ils sont
foutent
ils s'en foutent mais attention quand
même
il y a peut-être juste être puni par
Magnus en fait
c'est vrai que les dieux punissent pas
vraiment
que ça à faire
je ne joue pas avec ses bouts de bois de
merde ça m'intéresse pas intéressé par
ton jeu
ouais bah ouais mais mérité quand même
il a trop chanté
ah c'est terrible
c'est tellement mérité c'est tellement
karma de on va voir si réussi à se
reposer sur ses pattes
en fait
cette histoire mais bon il y a quand
même un fou une tour un pion
donc avoir à voir si ça peut se mettre
en mode forteresse et puis il a plus
trop de temps
et ça ça peut changer beaucoup de choses
c'est un peu comme un but avant une
mi-temps si si réussi à la gagner à
Magnus ça peut vraiment changer une
dynamique
place le foot de l'autre côté il
provoque Fouin F6 peut-être parce qu'il
tape 4
quand même
j'ai du mal à évaluer mais de toute
façon les blancs ils peuvent pas être
moins bien son forcément mieux en plus
ça pion
des carreau exactement
il y a peut-être faire un tour à 5 ou un
truc comme ça un moment donné pas tout
de suite là il peut pas mais essayer de
je sais pas d'organiser une attaque de
maths
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant c'est
dur à faire à cause de ce fou en prix si
tu le bouges je vais juste échanger ta
tour et la 6e
non toujours pas
attends on m'a dit là quand a priori ça
se voit peut-être un Mexico ah mais je
sais pas si c'est une info si il a
craqué ou non
ce serait vous qui serait juste
kidnapper par les narcos quoi
des histoires de kidnapping
c'est hyper dangereux comme endroit en
fait Mexico ce serait beau quoi
il s'appelle avec Denzel Washington
du film en fait il garde d'une petite
fille j'ai vu le film j'ai vu le film
ouais
ok on peut passer loin de la
correctionnel mais bon plus 4 il peut
être très content de ça session en 5
minutes avec
ouais ouais ouais ouais je pense pas
qu'il enfin mais je sais pas d'où il
tire l'info je sais pas s'il a mal lu un
truc enfin tu vois je sais pas trop j'ai
vu ça nulle part ailleurs donc je me
demandais mais
on verra bien si c'est confirmé ou pas
en tout cas ça nous arrange nous je
pense
parce que si je joue à 14h heure locale
de décalage avec Mexico
il est 14h45 on a ah on a que 7 heures
ok mais ça va enfin si c'est 14h 14 et 7
donc on a le temps de 1 2 3 heures du
mat tout le temps quoi
non mais oui un truc qui nous passe pas
nous on ne serait content soit à côté
Chine que ça joue tôt le matin soit bah
là-bas ou ça joue tard le soir ça se
fait des belles journées
mais peut-être que ça s'intéresse pas
trop là
encore une heure plus
parce que c'est quand même hyper loin
Mexico
c'est sur la hauteur de San Antonio
parce que New York c'est combien c'est
pas déjà 7h
[Musique]
d'hiver il change pas tous
c'est quand même
c'est au tordu quand ça quoi neveras
Oklahoma Texas
Dakota Sud Dakota Nord
ine c'est combien
bah je sais pas parce qu'en fait c'est
très bas mais
c'est un peu sur le même
ça s'appelle les méridien ces trucs
c'est quand même hyper loin de chez nous
c'est hyper loin
mais tu arrives jamais en fait
ils sont c'est en fait non
enfin un peu de choses près mais c'est
par là-bas c'est un peu les
on appelle ça
Caraïbes
[Musique]
en fait il faut un peu la jonction entre
l'Amérique du Sud et l'Amérique du Nord
ouais je crois que c'est pas mal enfin
j'ai jamais allé donc j'ai pas d'avis
perso mais
les gens que je connais qui sont allés
et moi c'est des gens il y a pas
longtemps qui m'ont raconté ça ils sont
parés vivre au Panama mais je sais plus
qui c'était
si ils ont pas fait une ferme ou un truc
comme ça
je serais bien faire un tour en Amérique
du Sud comme ça
[Musique]
tu es pas loin de la Colombie ouais tu
es pas forcément
Colombie ils me font peur
mais j'imagine c'est comme plein
d'endroit en fait si tombe pas pile au
mauvais endroit au même moment ça doit
bien se passer quand même je crois
Colombie c'est vraiment dangereux
partout tout le temps
je crois Colombie je pensais vraiment
parce que Barland quoi ouais non mais tu
sais où tu vas évidemment ça va mais je
pense que tu peux pas faire un road trip
comme on a fait tu vois
oui mais non c'est parce qu'on fait
oui oui non non c'est ça tu dois quand
même travailler ton truc à l'avance pas
trop tout seul au milieu de nulle part
Pérou ça aurait pu être tranquille déjà
c'est cool quelqu'un qui revient un lien
pour pour acheter des billets de match
un mec qui dit à Bogota j'ai vu un mec
se faire descendre devant moi ouais tu
vois c'est pas
je sais pas ça sent pas
très bon
la passe je pense en Bolivie ça va être
cool
et puis voir aussi tous les temples Maya
et ça j'avais fait je suis allé au
Mexique ça je l'ai fait
[Musique]
l'Uruguay ça va être cool aussi ah ça va
envie de voyager tout ça
Argentine plutôt mathémé Hugo
pour toi les graines non la capitale
[Musique]
en fait
Mexique ça aztèque Mexique c'est Maya
enfin ça dépend où
moi j'étais allé dans la rivière
capitale du Guatemala
j'ai su mais je me rappelle plus
je ne saurais dire
OK
Terre de Feu Argentine Rio Grande
pourquoi ils sont pas là
en fait il faut n'importe quoi
Santiago du Chili
j'avais un copain chilien ses parents
je prends des relais quoi
on roule comme des fous
mais bon faut pas qu'on aille dans
endroits pas trop dangereux quoi donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'on zappe un peu tout
le côté Amérique du Sud du Nord
mais je pense que Chili Argentine
Uruguay tout ça c'est safe je pense
il dit c'est pas très safe
non mais en fait
du tout ouais après moi j'ai de la
famille de ce Mexique
tu vois j'étais au contact d'histoire de
gens qui ont fait un rôti malade qui
sont retrouvés torse nu avec des gens
qui les braquait avec des Kalash tu vois
et c'est pas des histoires inventées ou
quoi tu vois et c'est genre c'est pas si
rare en fait
je le sens pas trop le délire
je sais pas faut qu'on réfléchisse femme
sinon on se fait en road trip pour
autant en Espagne qu'on est bien on a
nos marques quoi c'est vrai en fait
te parlera un peu la même langue qu'on
sera là ça va quand on pourra faire pour
pas s'y croire femme ok allez
peut-être ça craint vraiment quoi
du coup
alors ça repense quoi
il avait déjà fait un à trois un peu
bizarre dans un match précédent
es après c'est pas fou à trois mais
c'est pas un coup mauvais non plus c'est
un peu tu passes ton tour quoi et puis
tu joues un coup qui plus ou moins utile
la dernière là on 5 plus 1 oui c'est
passé des choses qui viennent du coup
c'est déjà plus violent
mais ouais avec les Noirs le jeu
faire ce changement de structure
dernièrement j'étais étonné
et il fait des têtes bizarres
que ça veut dire sa tête j'ai vraiment
vu quelqu'un faire autant de grimaces de
ma vie en fait mais en fait je me
demander réellement si il a pas commencé
à les faire tiens en mode délire
un peu comme un toc en fait tu vois
c'est vraiment ce que je me demande
donc je me demande je me demande si il
est pas
c'est à force d'en faire en fait c'est
pas un engrenage de la grimace en fait
bon je t'aime pas convaincu que sont des
c'est étrange
t'a donné un truc au blanc quand on est
pas temps
OK
bon là il est pas bien attention parce
que tu vois ça pouvait faire 7-2 et puis
ça peut-être faire 6 3 tout d'un coup
tout ne peut plus être si facile
après bon il en parlera bien une un jour
ou l'autre mais ouais c'est un peu tôt
là
c'est vrai que pas gagné la précédente
perdre celle-là sans mettre un petit
tournant dans la dynamique du match pour
l'instant était ultra favorable
après
n'est pas encore perdu d'ailleurs
celle-là juste bon ici j'ai l'impression
il a pas la tête des grands jours je te
le dis tout de suite
après avec ce virus il a peut-être il
est peut-être tombé sur l'épidémie
je pense que
doit suffire Fab
et de faire froid cela moi j'étais en
Bourbourg ils ont moins 10 quoi ouais
mais bon le virus sont vite attrapés
quand il fait sa température ça
t'affaiblit les muqueuses
[Musique]
c'était intéressant que le truc comme
ils expliquait qu'en fait tu as des
sortes de cellules dans le nez
ils sont pas vraiment des cellules en
fait c'est un truc un peu hybride à la
con mais qui ressemble beaucoup non
c'est pas tu respires et le virus qui
arrive donc le virus il son but c'est
d'aller se [ __ ] dans une cellule et
après de plus de partout et en fait on
était fausses cellules qui sont là c'est
très heureux il va dedans en fait il
fait juste capturer comme une merde et
il peut pas faire son truc depuis du
lait quoi il est juste enfermé et donc
voilà le système de défense nasale
contre les virus bon je caricature un
peu là ma mère de raconter mais le
problème c'est quand il fait froid ces
trucs là marche plus donc en fait
attrape le virus et puis là il rentre
même la crème de Vlad
il met une crème de lait alors l'hiver
en fait Vlad c'est vague en fait tous
les tous les hivers il m'a acheté une
crème quoi heureusement j'avais mon Vlad
donc bon et tu mets cette petite crème
donc tu l'as tu la déposes sur le nez et
donc quand tu respires en fait les virus
ils tombent dans la crème donc bon tu es
tranquille
bah c'est du Vlad quoi donc forcément
c'est vrai
la crème remplace tes fausses cellules
en gros quoi
jamais rien il m'a dit l'hiver c'est tu
mets cette crème et tu n'attrape rien
parce que nous ils nous disent mettre
des cache-nez quoi un truc du coup qui
te réchauffe le nez pour que tu es tes
trucs
tu dois bien la mettre bien autour que
ça te tapisse bien le contour du nez et
tu peux respirer tranquille les virus ne
peuvent plus rentrer ils sont ils sont
bloqués dans la crème en fait
et ça gagne autant en fait toutes les
parties sont gagnées au temps
ça
alors qu'est-ce qu'il en est
s'engueuler dans ce
dans ces Espagnols et c'est vrai que
c'est la première victoire de Magnus
dans ce match
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure idée du
monde pour ikaro j'ai des trois des
grandes lignes de matchs
[Musique]
c'est la première partie ouais
mais pourquoi retourner là-dedans
c'est pas c'est complètement con non
peut-être qu'il a regardé mais ça a
l'air con
il a juste
[Musique]
mais ils ont déjà joué ça avec le matin
jusque là il y a pas eu une seule
différence non finale on se dit tiens
est-ce que Magnus peut peut-être pas
jouer ou quoi
en tout cas c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour Magnus Cyrus
et les quatre trois c'est cinq peut-être
et tu vas après
bon on va voir si
[Musique]
la plus vérifié de trois trucs une
petite idée pour tendre une sorte de
piège pratique
bon derrière
ça des retours avec le
de rentrer dans ce truc là
bon après c'est peut-être juste qu'il
veut
il veut comment dire
passer le temps qui sait que ça il va
faire nul et qui veut juste faire passer
cinq minutes
mais je pense pas que ce soit une bonne
idée non plus
[Musique]
que quand tu peux mettre la tête sous
l'eau faut la mettre quoi
faut pas laisser reprendre ses esprits
quoi après il y a eu la pause machin ça
va vite non non mais complètement enfin
c'est pas c'est pas si facile à faire
parce que je raconte mais tu as des
moments de Tom quoi des moments c'est
comme ça il faut appuyer
c'est trop tôt pour gérer quoi
pour ceux qui ont suivi le rugby hier
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé entre La
Rochelle et lolster
ils étaient fantomatique
à La Rochelle il prenait les points
machin il prenait les trois points il
s'est ultra pragmatique bon ils mène 29
zéro à la mi-temps
tu dis bon ils ont peut-être quand même
un peu trop pragmatique tu vois parce
que bon 29 à zéro
tu sens que tu devines quoi en fait le
match c'est fini 29 36 en fait les
autres on vous a mis temps ils sont pas
revenus du tout avec les mêmes
intentions et
ils étaient hyper dangereux et ils ont
bien joué juste mais genre oui en fait
ils ont mis le maximum de points avec
leur momentum possible et il est prenait
très au sérieux et ils ont compris que
enfin compris ou pas mais ils ont senti
le danger quoi que si ça revenait dans
le match ça pouvait ça pouvait être dur
et
et du coup un peu la même chose ici avec
Magnus dans le sens où ok il est mené au
score et tout mais tu sais que
faut pas
le remettre dedans
il faut quand même continuer à
concrétiser au maximum parce que là bon
si commence à lui faire du BK
[Musique]
donc tu le remets aussi dedans dans le
dans le comportement quoi
il te remet un peu mal au temps il peut
y avoir des fourchettes en fait c'est
même lui qui va jouer le gain
S
la prochaine et c'est très chaud
ce que deux points après c'est vraiment
rien
tu as un vrai
un vrai matelas mais deux points
il commence à être mieux là
attention de pas la perdre quand même
côté Magnum
il va te faire Roader 4 puis c'est 3
ça fait un tour
à l'aise avec les Blancs enfin je sais
pas c'est impression que tu peux que
perdre cette merde
après c'est aussi parce que c'est Magnus
on a peur
bien joué là elle sera pour toi 4
il va remettre le cavalier en D2 il te
coupe il va prendre 5 à 5 pardon chacun
de son pion
le mec il peut danser avec l'autre mais
bon un fou c'est plus fort dans cette
situation
OK
[Musique]
on va mettre la tour derrière
ok mais bon
quand même
en tout cas
il est déjà en mode gestion et le match
est long encore il reste beaucoup de
parties à Fab
faut pas que ça se retourne contre lui
après il pense peut-être dominer en
belette mais c'est même pas sûr avec le
plus une seconde
attention que ça ressemble pas France
Argentine
avant le match tu lis tu arrives à
égalité au belote ici quoi
c'est peut-être Condé du coup
je repars c'est sur les scénarios qui
font les matchs
bon cela dit on n'est pas encore à zéro
il y aura plus 3
je sais pas si il écoute de la musique
pendant son match
ça va qui s'écoute le frites from desire
[Musique]
aussi et ce serait beau que Swan
à cause de la Coupe du monde
je sais pas sur la revue en tête
c'est une belle musique ah mais j'aime
bien moi j'ai rien contre mais
avant le chat ils sont très heureux
[Musique]
attention on laisse pas tourner vite
ça fait longtemps que j'entends que
j'entends dans les soirées moi je fais
pas trop de soirée en fait c'est ça le
problème
peut-être mais bon
écoutez ça elle était 97 quoi mais de
mémoire mais je sais pas
mais je sais que c'était pas en vacances
j'étais très heureuse dans ma chambre tu
es un peu comme un petit Célestin quoi
[Musique]
mais en fait j'aime bien toujours en
fait ça
je suis étonné que ça revienne
maintenant quoi la finale
elle est complètement nul non
je vois pas trop comment est-ce que tu
peux faire d'autre avec les Blancs
[Musique]
il va quand même essayer de la jouer
mais oui il va pas il va pas réussir à
faire grand-chose
il a raison
[Musique]
il fait une sieste ça y est il a fermé
les yeux et très heureux
lesquels quand même
non mais j'en peux plus en fait c'est
tellement du foutage de gueule non-stop
[Musique]
ah il est très heureux il se voit son
petit
je te chie dessus regarde c'est
magnifique en fait
les vieux RMC ouais ouais
après ça genre autre chose vaut mieux le
faire derrière son ordi derrière une
caméra quand même
Franck il fait ça contre Fab en partie
réelle
non
je crois que ça se passe pas très bien
malheureusement je pourrais rien faire
mais je serai pas très content mais bon
oui ils sont blessent plus taper sur la
gueule et qu'on met pas parti perdu je
pense ça serait mérité
mais là en fait pour le coup il a raison
de faire enfin je sais pas ce qu'il fait
je vois pas la cam mais de pas jouer
d'attendre ça j'ai aucun reproche là
dessus
quoi c'est du talon je suis fermes les
yeux là il refait des grimaces de
partout enfin c'est
ah oui en vrai c'est juste que tu
[Musique]
peux pas faire ça en fait c'est pas
possible
de ce format mais bon
ça fait rien
au final c'est possible en fait il veut
juste faire des nuls quoi il est
magnifique
c'est exceptionnel ce qui vient de faire
quand même OK
[Musique]
etc après juste pour être très clair
notre philosophie avec Fab ça a toujours
été la suivante en fait les échecs ce
format en fait il peut pas exister en
soi enfin les échecs ça se joue c'est un
comptage de points c'est exactement
comme quand au tennis ils ont essayé de
faire leur tournoi avec du temps en fait
ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne va pas en
fait c'est pas des jeux qui sont joués
pour pour jouer comme ça et donc c'est
c'est le règlement qui crée cette
attitude et pas l'inverse en réalité
six saisons maintenant de speechers ils
ont toujours pas changé donc bah en fait
c'est comme ça enfin c'était peut-être
qu'ils sont contents ça se passe comme
ça aussi mais
mais c'est quelque part c'est une faille
dans le règlement que les joueurs
exploite parce que bah ils ont le droit
et que ça permet d'être en gestionnaire
dans le match mais en gros les échecs
c'est pas un jeu que je la montre parce
que tu gagnes une partie en dix minutes
ou en huit heures tu marques un point
et que tu perds en un coup ou 90 c'est
pas mieux enfin que tu gagnes ça y est
il y a pas de mérite à gagner vite quoi
et là bon bref là c'est un peu à
l'inverse parce que comme tu es limité
en temps et c'est pas un nombre de
parties contrairement par la finale
champion du monde ils disent en 12
parties en 14 parties ou quoi c'est
comme s'il disait bah on a on a 20
heures de jeu en tout vous venez chaque
jour et puis bah quand c'est fini c'est
fini dès que tu mènes au score tu joues
la montre quoi en fait c'est ce que fait
carou maintenant mais c'est ce qui
existe pas aux échecs normalement quoi
en fait
je me suis décalé est-ce que ça sent ça
sent le brûler en fait mais ça vient pas
de chez moi
[Musique]
et donc ouais pour revenir à la partie
bon j'espère qu'il y a pas de feu chez
elle
ouais donc en fait on a une structure un
peu qui ressemble aux États d'un coup
mais avec moins d'attaque pour les noirs
et le roi c'est
souvent difficile dans les Espagnols à
faire
donc après on va pas échanger les fous
de case noire avec les Blancs c'est pas
le bon fout des noirs
dans cette position le plan stratégique
entre guillemets donc c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il fait cailler les deux pour
aller se replacer vers B3 et enlever ce
cavalier de c'est 5 et une fois que lui
il sera plus là c'est blanc foncé 5 ils
avancent du côté ils ont plus d'espace
et voilà ça a été de retour ouais ouais
je pense c'est les gens qui ont fait des
pétards ou un truc comme ça
sent plus à l'extérieur non non ça se
voit je sais pas ça sent plus comme des
feux d'artifice ou des conneries comme
ça argentins qui viennent fêter là mais
je voulais quand même aller vérifier
parce que le feu ça fait peur
et donc ça devient ça se passe bien pour
les carreaux ou quoi
trois 7 comme là avec trois cadences oh
non juste qu'il fasse du 3 + 5 il fasse
des 7 en fait tout bêtement ou du 5 + 1
s'ils veulent
de quoi la question qui fasse des 7
genre tu as gagné un 7 en gagnant de
thèmes soit ils font des ça tu vois ils
disent bah il y a 10
parties de 5 minutes 8 de chaque
6 c'est pas ce qu'ils veulent quoi et où
les 7 mais j'aime bien l'idée
comme ils veulent en fait mais cette
histoire de temps oui ça va un peu à
l'encontre du principe même du jeu
mais la raison c'est comme le tennis
c'est pas un truc qui joue longtemps
quoi un tennis ils ont tenté aussi ils
ont tenté mais ils ont vite changé
d'avis ouais après ils ont profité de la
période covid pour tenter des trucs un
peu un peu spéciaux mais j'ai eu un très
long article là-dessus en fait
sur pourquoi ça a été fait en fait c'est
prendre ce soit pour les diffuseurs
j'imagine non ouais ouais c'est parce
que tu vends plus cher la publicité si
tu vends du temps que si tu vends un
truc que tu sais pas combien de temps ça
dure
mais je peux comprendre que pour un
diffuseur soit bien plus agréable de
savoir tu fais ta grille tu sais que tu
as un match de 17h à 19h point final il
y aura pas de cinquième set ou de je
sais pas quoi tu sais quand tu mets tes
pubs tu sais tout donc ça je comprends
mais en fait juste enfin c'est pas de
chance c'est pas un jeu un sport qui est
fait pour ça et
ça marche pas quoi enfin ouais ça va à
l'encontre de la nature du sport ouais
bon après là c'est un truc une fois dans
l'année ça va oui on s'est un peu mais
là pour le coup je sais pas s'ils
vendent des pubs quoi tu es comme je
suis pas sûr mais je pense qu'il
pourrait un poil modifier le truc pour
garder un peu ce format là qui est quand
même pas mal
mais un poids à l'amélioré quoi qui est
pas ces trucs de jouer la montre au
moins
c'est pas pour cette année ça c'est sûr
puisque c'est le dernier match peut-être
l'an prochain la finale pourrait durer
plus longtemps aussi d'ailleurs
comme un comme les finales du Master à
l'époque etc
ça pourrait mais bon c'est déjà c'est
long les autres qui doit durer moins
longtemps et celui-là restez à cette
cadence oui ou dans ce sens là oui si tu
préfères mais en soi ça me paraîtrait
pas délirant d'avoir la finale plus
longue dans ce déjà
c'est juste qu'il y a plus de pause pour
être bien sûr
j'ai bien aimé la décision pratique de
Carlson en fait de filer le pion pour
garder ce qui a laissé 5 et avoir des
conations on va dire il souffre quand
même il a un purement mais
il tient bien la baraque qui t'empêche
de rentrer en baisser avec la tour il
attaque à 4 ou qui n'empêche l'autre
tour de faire ce qu'elle veut touche 4
aussi et ouais donc ça fait beaucoup de
choses je sais pas je sais même pas si
les blancs objectivement sont vraiment
mieux il peut la perdre ça c'est hyper
Sala c'est un tournant je t'annonce
parce que c'est le genre de partie qui
peut perdre après tu fais que tu auras
trois tours je crois qu'il va peut-être
pas grand chose
et puis
tu vas revenir et
attention quand même
mais bon tu commences à faire nuit tout
c'est des petits aveux de faiblesse à
chaque fois
mais ko il est assez pragmatique il va
pas jouer au con je pense
[Musique]
je dois gagner parce que j'étais mieux
en fait faut rejeter la position comme
elle est pas comment il était et mieux
effectivement tu as raté tu as raté si
maintenant c'est égal ça y est et on a
tous fait les cons à cause de ça dans
notre vie dans notre carrière et elle a
finir par perdre tout seul au lieu de
bah tant pis c'est nul c'est nul à moi
combien de fois je les fais ça terrible
en fait c'est un défaut que tout le
monde a en fait enfin que du coup tu
apprends peut-être à corriger ou pas
selon les personnes mais très à quand on
est jeune on est fougueux impulsif et on
fait la connerie et
en fait même après ça peut arriver quoi
donc il faut
et pareil dans l'autre sens en fait et
dans l'autre sens on le fait encore plus
souvent c'est quand on est foutu
qu'en fait on revient dans la partie et
que peut-être même on est mieux en fait
on est tellement content de pas perdre
que nul c'est bon je suis soulagé mais
en fait non
mais ça j'ai fait les deux
mais ça a été tellement content
A5
après c'est un peu dangereux mais bon
priori pourquoi pas mais là il y a pas
accueille C4 et même idée
ah là il y avait 4 attaquer mais en fait
tu vas te le prendre ce [ __ ] de
français 7 enfin je vais au bout d'un
moment
pardon désolé mais tout à l'heure je
pense ça marche
champion du monde d'échec mesdames et
messieurs
c'est pas de bol
en bas oui
ça joue quand même pas très bien côté
magmouche
il écoute le stream en fait
je suis content
je fais les mêmes blagues
les mêmes caves que Magnus
ah c'est pas de bol
ça là elle fait mal
il est pas dans son assiette Magus alors
est-ce que c'est parce que Hikaru le met
en danger est-ce que c'est parce qu'il a
je crois que ça vient de lui enfin il
fait son match
il se joue gravement quoi
est-ce que c'est parce qu'il est mis en
difficulté par Ikaru est-ce que c'est
parce que il a chopé un truc c'est la
période en ce moment
après des fois c'est aussi un peu des
vases communicants enfin tu donnes la
concentration adversaire qui va jouer
d'autant mieux toi tu te rends compte
que tu fais le compte tu es pas dans ton
assiette donc
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est le plug qui a plus de
batterie nous dit dans le chat
ça peut aussi on ne sait pas en parlant
de Flag il y a eu un truc incroyable qui
a été déclaré par défaut en fait
ok je peux au courant c'est pas si tu as
vu non en fait
il parle de son match contre en chineman
parce que j'utilise un ordi aussi quoi
[Rires]
il en perd 3 4 il dit OK et du coup j'ai
allumé la turbine pour jouer contre lui
et il a continué à me battre
mais je sais pas j'ai halluciné en fait
que
c'était juste un tricheur de merde enfin
tu es juste une merde en fait
qui était trop sûr
non mais je sais mais en fait je gère
pas oui mais moi je vais te le faire en
bas de championnat du monde et puis je
vais être sûr aussi enfin
je comprends pas en fait
j'ai halluciné sur le truc mais il te
dit ça normal en fait genre oui bon je
voulais vérifier pour être vraiment sûr
qui tricher bon ben j'en étais enfin il
trouve ça normal complètement normal
mais en fait je veux dire enfin en fait
tu dois
écrire dans le chat tu as plus un
arbitre enfin faire un truc mais tu dois
pas faire ça ça c'est clair mais bon
après je peux comprendre le tilt sur le
moment après c'est juste étonnant d'en
parler si librement mais Eddy il a dit
sur une vidéo j'ai vu le truc
mais non mais après je comprends le truc
c'est juste que tu en as marre t'as
aucun tricheur qui se fait jamais
attraper donc et que tu dis ok bon joint
dans le cornet parce que je suis juste
parano ou quoi
mais du coup c'est étonnant qui perdent
malgré la turbine enfin c'est que si
c'est pas bien s'en servir
mais oui si tu as la turbine tu perds
pas normalement en tout cas pas contre
un humain mais non mais après je
comprends l'histoire c'est juste que oui
ça sent l'histoire de enfin c'est de
bonne foi mais genre par là c'est c'est
juste pour dire l'ambiance qui peut
régner se fait en le faisant il juste il
voulait perdre le match enfin en fait il
abandonne le match il va être sûr je
pense en fait non mais c'est juste
c'est ça corrobore un peu ce dont on a
parlé pendant un moment c'est que
l'ambiance dans les échecs elle est
délétère en fait parce que ça c'était
avant le
le machin le scandale de hand c'est tout
et les mecs ils en sont au point de
tricher eux-mêmes tellement ils sont
sûrs que les autres triches quoi
c'est à l'occasion c'est un truc un peu
comme ça je sais pas si c'est un speed
chasse ou un autre truc similaire mais
c'était
des parties amicales OK
juste d'un coup en fait il a commencé à
me défoncer et enfin on comprend pas
quoi faire
j'ai mis la turbine il continue à me
défoncer bon bah j'ai compris quoi
[Musique]
non mais je trouvais que c'était assez
comment dire
caractéristique
c'est pas le mot mais assez ordre
ça montre un peu l'ambiance qu'il y a
mais voilà c'est on en parle plus trop
non
tapis et reparti sous le tapis ouais ça
c'est pas ça c'est pas arrangé mais
c'est reparti sous le tapis
il y a quelques trucs un peu
[Musique]
intéressant on va dire ça comme ça il y
a des joueurs qui étaient très forts sur
chetcom qui depuis peu là sont devenus
beaucoup moins forts un peu plus jouable
un peu plus jouable alors est-ce que
c'est parce que
quelle est la raison ça j'en sais rien
mais
dans le timing
il y a des
trucs
j'ai honnêtement aucune information
là-dessus c'est juste un
le regard d'un œil de quelqu'un qui joue
beaucoup sur chaccom et qui joue
beaucoup de tournois mais il y a
[Musique]
il y a des joueurs qui étaient très bons
et qui jouent plus alors est-ce que
c'est parce qu'ils sont en vacances ce
qui est possible aussi ou est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il joue des tournants en
réel en ce moment et donc on les voit
plus trop est-ce que c'est je n'ai pas
la réponse raisonnablement mais on peut
pas dire que ce soit complètement sous
le tapis en fait
il y a aussi quelques gants en réels qui
sont fait choper au-delà de ça
mais c'est pas le seul
OK
dans des compétitions jeunes
chez les jeunes
et ça corrobore avec les trucs qu'on
pensait quoi donc intéressant donc
je sais pas pourquoi vous jouez les gars
c'est horrible c'est encore pire je
pense ouais mais bon c'est pour l'argent
parce que c'est souvent des pays où il y
a beaucoup de sorry et
non mais en fait que enfin bon déjà il y
a jamais de raison pour tricher mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est comme c'est un
SDF qui va te voler un truc dans un
magasin je comprends ce qui se passe tu
as pas volé mais bon ok bon et aux
échecs peut-être c'est un mec il a
absolument besoin d'un prix il va ranger
une partie où il va tricher donc bon
déjà il a pas le faire mais je peux
rends le raisonnement mais là en fait tu
étais juste un enfant tu dois avoir
l'innocence tu dois juste jouer parce
que tu es content de jouer après c'est
les entraîneurs Fab ouais enfin c'est
encore
c'est Nantes mais
c'est encore pire que les mecs qui
veulent juste monter leur hello ou
gagner des prix ou
la motivation qui est enfin que de toute
façon ça excuse pas et puis une fois on
doit juste suspendre et je veux plus
entendre parler mais en plus les
adresses c'est horrible de faire un
gamin quoi
c'est vrai
mais ouais ouais mais après c'est la
pause du coup c'est bien pour moi quand
un entraîneur tu es aussi un éducateur
dire que tu dois apprendre le mieux que
tu peux à mieux jouer aux échecs ok
certes mais tu es aussi être un peu un
modèle à prendre des valeurs quoi
et là tu apprends juste être une merde
en fait donc c'est
doublement un truc en fait
c'est un tricheur de merde en plus
non mais bon c'était juste pour dire il
y a des progrès qui sont faits
actuellement on peut pas dire que rien
ne soit fait
ok c'est bien ça va dans le bon sens
tant mieux il y a quand même des choses
qui vont dans le bon sens on peut pas
dire l'inverse après le problème semble
quand même complètement insoluble
mais
on peut dire que il y a le maximum est
fait quoi enfin on se rapproche du
maximum petit à petit
mais c'est vraiment un problème aux
échecs
et tu vois j'étais vraiment étonné le
truc de népo j'étais vraiment étonné
je trouve ça c'est limite marrant mais
ouais
mais c'est enfin c'est ce dont parle on
les échecs c'est que c'est que c'est pas
si mal vu que ça de tricher en fait
c'est ça le problème
non mais lui pour le coup enfin il a
vraiment pas rentrer chez quand il l'a
fait pour je sais mais
j'ai que c'est tout le monde peut se
trouver c'est facile de trouver des
excuses
c'est très facile
ça vient vers la vidéo non mais après
c'est des parties amicales sur internet
donc c'est normal qui est pas de bas en
réel ou quoi que ce soit sinon on va ok
Magnus aussi doit être banavie etc enfin
tu en as quand même beaucoup tu aurais
plus grand monde du top niveau si tu
enlèves tous les gens qui ont sur au
moins une fois
tu vas enlever 80% des joueurs ou 90 %
des joueurs en réalité
mais ouais ouais c'est compliqué
dans trois quatre minutes
c'est championnat du monde je sais plus
où c'était
demander le tournage jeune il y avait eu
des problèmes c'est un championnat du
monde donc je sais plus où il était mais
c'était c'était des joueurs qui étaient
vraiment forts
c'est pas de la triche parce que le gars
le dérangeait plus que les dés en
général bon alors c'est non
mais quand tu as des potes qui te
donnent des coups à côté de toi quand tu
joues et que tu joues les coups qu'on
donne ça s'appelle tricher c'est pas
on va ça c'est genre dans le chat sont
complètement fous non ça ça s'appelle
tricher t'as pas tu as pas avoir de gens
qui te donne des coups à jouer à côté de
toi en fait ça n'existe pas en fait
il y a pas de règle ou tu peux jouer à
deux sur le même ordi en fait c'est
surtout dans des tournois il y a de
l'argent c'est
l'intention n'est pas la même quand même
oui non mais en fait enfin on va pas
commencer à parler d'intention enfin
c'est je sais pas c'est comme si tu
voles un truc tu voles en fait je sais
pas comment dire ça me rend fou sa femme
c'est pas toi oui non mais oui
[Musique]
c'est juste que si on t'a chopé en
flagrant délit en train de faire ça qui
me dit qu'il fait pas plus grave à côté
enfin je sais pas en fait c'est
il y a pas à dire que ça c'est plus
grave que ça c'est moins grave bon ben
sinon c'est trop facile en fait
c'est comme ça mais
[Musique]
mais évidemment il y aura pas de
sanction pour ces trucs là c'est sûr
parce que ça reste sur des parties
amicales sur Internet et que voilà mais
ça dénote plus d'une atmosphère ce que
je voulais dire en fait
qui est pas terrible les mecs se
soupçonnent les mecs machins donc ouais
c'est pas
c'est pas super gai mais il y a des
progrès qui sont faits en ce moment et
ça c'est plutôt la bonne nouvelle
est-ce que Magnus est supérieur avec
Caron belette
normalement non mais bon on verra
ben non mais bon là sur le match
en fait
beaucoup plus fort il a plus qu'à gérer
je pense aussi ouais
elle est partie par correspond qu'on
peut tricher ou c'est pareil alors les
parties par correspondance officielle en
fait tu es encouragé à utiliser
l'ordinateur justement comme il pouvait
pas contrôler ils ont décidé de
d'autoriser
ouais maintenant la correspond ça c'est
que ça bah d'ailleurs il y a quasiment
plus de victoire
il faut que des nuls et
à haut niveau je pense ça doit pas être
facile genre demain on se met à la
correspondance je pense qu'on se fait
défoncer
en fait
mais pendant longtemps l'ordinateur aidé
mais faisait pas forcément une
différence enfin il faisait une
différence mais
la guidance du joueur était quand même
importante j'ai l'impression que avec
les dernières
avancées ça de ça devient de moins en
moins
alors c'est reparti
en fait alors bon allez prends nous du
pion cette fois du fou je veux dire non
je crois que la partie là où il a donné
une pièce en plus il était bien à mainus
elle fait quand même très mal
c'est équilibre largement les petits
ratés dans la Sicilienne tout à l'heure
et la partie perdue complètement
et ouais attention par contre les
parties par correspondance sur Chester
on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser
l'ordinateur
[Musique]
un truc super ok si Magnus trouve
cavalier B5 puis on prend B5 tours c'est
ça dame français 5 fourchettes ok
largement trouvable pour un mec du
calibre de Magnus
y penser OK
en fait il écoute le stream
ok ça ça peut le relancer
mais pour un joueur de ce calibre là si
tu penses en fait c'est pas très dur
parce que c'est tout forcé
avec intérêt ton matériel quand tu auras
un tour de plus une structure pourrie tu
as trouvé en quoi et ça te relance un
peu parce que tu reviens à trois points
si tu recolles à deux
carreaux a pas vu c'est pas souvent
et la dame prend à 8 ça fait mal
il veut essayer d'enfermer
bah écoute c'est peut-être le meilleur
choix
[Musique]
oui non c'est moi qui divague
mais là qui est ici non
on le fait il sortira donc il fait ce
qu'il veut avec les Blancs il y a pas il
y a pas de danger
mais nous il nous faut encore chier
moi je suis là
et sur quoi après cavaluation 4 des 5
juste
c'est là que tu sens qu'il est quand
même pas serein
parce que c'est pas normal de prendre
autant de temps
pour un joueur de son calibre
des chances mais oui on est surpris mais
pour l'instant il mérite amplement de
d'être devant au score
après c'est pas forcément faible parce
que là Carlsen devrait gagner donc il
reviendra à trois points donc ce qui a
mis une marge mais il restera pas mal de
parties il y a des bullets il y a donc
ça peut encore revenir mais belle
chance de gagner ce match mais bon
ouais
le fait qu'il galère autant à gagner ça
enfin galérer c'est un grand mot parce
qu'il va y arriver mais tu sens qu'il
est pas patron quoi même dans des
parties comme ça
et ça c'est inquiétant je trouve
pour les supporters de Magnus
OK
mais il est hyper dangereux
ouais c'est pour ça que ça va être aussi
dur de revenir pour pour Magnus c'est
que
en fait même des parties comme ça là
j'ai l'impression qu'il en gagne pas 10
sur 10
même un truc comme ça il peut se faire
retourner
ce qui est ultra inquiétant
[Musique]
de faire des trucs comme ça un peu
ça va pas aller bien normalement mais
bon ouais mais
enfin c'est chiant quand même
voilà le roi va partir et ça va aller
mais
c'est peut-être il prend
et en plus ce truc c'est qu'il va te la
jouer
faire tourner le temps va te faire
tourner le temps
il va te faire tourner le temps à fond
donc il va jouer encore il reste combien
de temps portion de 3 + 1 il reste 16
minutes
[Musique]
ouais mais tu vois à quel point il fait
jouer
les dames
[Musique]
il joue il joue
mais il a raison
il veut plus des nuls de la
du Marshall il envoie une pierre
la spécialité
tu connais
tu peux bouffer la dame et il faut F2
c'est ce qui va faire je pense ouais
ouais c'est bon
minutes
après tu as le droit de jouer hein
[Musique]
tu changes de ligne avant quoi
il va temporiser
une position pendant 2030 où il y aura
pas un coup de jouer mais c'est le
format du match qui veut ça il vient de
perdre avant il est devant au score il
faut il a raison de gérer
ça a duré trois minutes cette histoire
donc il va rester plus de 12 minutes
plus ou moins
et donc ça lui fait jouer plus que deux
parties et donc au pire des cas il se
dit ok je serai devant pour le Bullet on
sait très bien joué donc
en fait en termes de stratégie de match
il a raison voilà
c'est très très bien joué
après ce qui est insupportable c'est
grimace pendant qu'il le fait
je peux pas j'ai pas le côté
insupportable j'ai juste le côté
stratège
ouais mais c'est
je peux pas critiquer le choix du
carreau
j'aimerais bien mais je peux pas
c'est juste les grimaces que je trouve
un peu de trop
après j'ai quand même envie qu'il perde
du coup
Magnus l'a un peu fait contre Maxime
aussi mais quand même un niveau bien
moindre
pas du tout de faire ça autant des fois
je peux te critiquer avec lui si il fait
des trucs que j'aime pas
mais là
c'est vraiment les grimaces c'est vrai
que les grimaces rajoutent un peu quand
même
mais il a raison de le faire
très clairement je ferai pareil à sa
place
je pense que
c'est sûr
peut-être avec même plus de grimaces
de carbone
[Musique]
il envoie du A3 à fond quoi
en 2018
c'est
ultra théorique
bon pour le moment Magnus qui reste
serein
attention quand même de pas trop faire
d'enfu Rada côté côté carreau parce que
l'écart s'amenuisent ils donnent des
nuls facile au blanc il suffit qu'il
perde ça là qui refasse une nulle qu'il
en joue une fin tu vois Magnus les
blancs quand même il peut il peut te
faire mal faut qu'il joue celle-là une
autre et point final
mais là ici
[Musique]
en face c'est préparé quoi
ça a dû travailler un peu le truc
il a l'air de connaître
ça c'est sûr
il connaît encore c'est sûr
pas mal d'éléments qui font que c'est
que c'est intéressant
[Musique]
si tu prends le 5 je peux prendre des B7
et F7
donc plutôt comme
oui
tu vas te [ __ ]
et tu es moins bien mais que peut-être
c'est pas la fin du monde
c'est bien joué c'est bien joué
et pas mal après je gère même [ __ ] en
B5 c'est pas absurde enfin il y aura
d'un point 5 bon bah du coup c'est
égalité matérielle elle fout pourra
revenir en C4 tu remets un peu de
pression tu as un tour de contrat là-bas
mais sur les Noirs espèrent avec la
[ __ ] que reposer avoir assez pour
défendre et puis en F4 qui peut aller en
F3 un peu affaiblir le roi adverse donc
ça sera ça les arguments noirs mais ça
doit être objectivement mieux pour les
blancs
en fait il faut prendre les cinq dames
prends le 5 tu 4 le calcul déjà
mais Magnus tu vois c'est sur des
moments comme ça où je le trouve pas
incisif
un peu lent par rapport à d'habitude
ok mais c'est bien joué
en dessin ou s'il y a plutôt en dessin
donc qui gêne un peu long de cette
colonne
et voir comment il continue maintenant
mais on est d'accord qu'il est pas
incisif Magnus
il manque d'incisibilité en fait
alors kikaru il est très incisif je
trouve
en fait il est capable d'accélérer
mais Magnus juste enfin vraiment il se
ressemblent pas quoi
que d'habitude
OK
au moins il pourra jouer sa pendule quoi
que ça va être longtemps à gagner si ça
gagne
faut que ça gagne mais je le vois pas là
il a gagné
pour le suspense du match façon faut
qu'il en gagne je pensais quand même
c'est pas le cas donc je pense que nul
en fait c'est même normal vu la position
ah c'est sûr que c'est normal
ça pour les blancs évidemment c'est
chiant mais
en fait tu vas te bloqué à un moment
donné dans ta progression
c'est ça je pense à faire
[Musique]
il est quand même bien bloqué
avec son sa tour ah mais attends
maintenant peut-être qu'il peut jouer
pour la 6e rangée
aussi
je le trouve vraiment parce que
ah [ __ ] c'est hyper fort
il va mettre le four en G4 et F7 F8
pourquoi il a abandonné
peut-être en tout cas bien joué Magnus
qui revient
normalement je vais être à moins de
la finale machin
mais attention quand même carreau je le
trouve un peu trop gestionnaire mais
après
parce que ouais c'est pas du grand
Magnus qu'on a
mais bon
quand même intéressé de voir les
interviews d'après match pour comprendre
s'il y a une raison pour qui on fait qui
jouait
pas trop bien moins bien aujourd'hui ça
c'est un nouveau coup dans A4 je crois
les épisodes
avec un genre de tour de un machin
qui est décidée
qui réfléchit
il va y avoir des échanges massifs non
genre rabais AB il faut prendre des cinq
pions tour des uns tu prends des deux
tours en dessin qui est nul
je pense
bien sûr
un match
qui est dans un faux rythme
mais Caro qui aura perdu deux points
faudra pas regretter une giga gestion
ça va tout échanger
F3 4 c'est pareil
je préfère un F3 c'est juste du temps il
est parti dans un domaine land
et donc on va se taper cette finale
pendant encore un peu de temps ça sonne
dans combien de temps le truc 40
secondes
c'est ça
un famed
format ade
je pense pas que si c'est Magnus qui
avait l'avantage il aurait fait ça
je sais pas je pense pas non mais en
plus il doit se sentir confiant de jouer
parce que
mais
ouais
après c'est malin
c'est juste pas très agréable pour les
spectateurs c'est tout en fait ouais
mais bon
juste normal
ça fait partie du jeu
du coup c'est combien de temps
je pense 10 minutes OK et après c'est
une demi-heure de pilote sans pause non
malheureusement sans pause ouais
tu donnes combien de pourcentage de
chance à Magnus
quand même
ouais
quand même deux points de retard
oui je sais
mais la dynamique ça va un peu mieux
et puis il a un orgueil quoi après oui
je pense quand même Kiko normalement
quand je dis 30 c'est que quand même
c'était très favori dans 70% de chance
mais il est pas hyper pas mort quoi
mais tu as pas trouvé Hikaru plus rapide
quand même dans le match sur les
parkings
le vainqueur gagne 20 000 en gros là sur
la finale peut-être un peu moins mais il
a déjà gagné des prix avant
ouais en fait 20000 c'est pas énorme
par rapport au standard
surtout
bah c'est dur quoi
en tout cas on va éviter de fixer
même une demi-heure c'est long mais il y
a pas de temps de partie que ça gagne
deux premières c'est fini par exemple
après la finale c'est possible c'est
possible chez qui joue dessus après je
sais pas si c'est une info mais pourquoi
pas parce qu'il faut bien se vider la
tête il va pas il va pas se taper la
tête contre les murs mais fais une bonne
rentrée quand même
non il est pas très bien tiré je suis
d'accord ça mi hauteur mais bon c'est
cadré quand même vers le petit filet et
je pense tu tires comme ça tu en marque
souvent en fait
tu peux pas juste apprendre à tirer dans
la lucarne en fait
je pense que ça fait mais après 120
minutes avec l'enjeu le stress le machin
c'est un risque de la photo dessus
et à mon avis ça joue ça joue grandement
quoi
faites tu as juste envie de faire ton
intérieur du pied tranquille
genre
le Brésil finalement le 94 je pense
qu'il veut dire la lucarne il a foutu un
peu là-bas ou très aiguë en 2006 il tire
lucarne ma BIM ça fait la barre
ou de voir le goal partir d'un côté et
ok
ça te fait chier de retirer bien avec
120 minutes dans les pâtes et
c'est en jeu quoi
enfin il frappe il frappe bien cette
gueule qui sera normal quoi ça fait
chier d'ailleurs
mais franchement il arrête pas ça
reprise si vous souvenez de 98 et une
occasion comme ça il fait une frappe
toute moche écrasée à côté du guitares
ça c'était vraiment des trucs raté quoi
bon sans conséquence pour le coup et là
en fait il la tape bien quand même c'est
le goal alors après peut-être fallait
lever je sais pas d'ailleurs j'ai posé
la question à couper là sur sur Twitter
je sais pas si il me répondra
elle parviendra du poteau mais l'autre
il prend vraiment une place de ouf dans
les cages c'est un gold quoi tu as
l'impression elle t'a vu ce truc de
hors-jeu sur le butin argentin avec la
main qui dépasse mais elle est pas
importante
oui non mais par contre il y a un truc
marrant c'est que l'armée de pouvoir
faisait le troisième but
parce que les remplaçants sont rentrés
dans la pelouse avant qu'il y a but
[Musique]
on va voir et puis on va voir si il
arrive à accélérer ou quoi
en tout cas il fait [ __ ] 4 fois pas
terrible
ça commence pas très bien pour Magnus
Fab c'est le premier coup
c'est pas pas très rassurant mais bon la
position est encore correcte
ok bon on va voir bon on fait changer
j'imagine madame B4 ok
il y a un joli dame prend B2 si vous
voyez le ouais
bonus
c'est des grosses fautes ou des trois
ils seront en cavalière 4 enfin
Dieu que swap de mon assiette je dis
ouais voilà c'est ça
ouais mais là si Magnus
redresse pas la barre dès la prochaine à
mon avis c'est déjà terminé voilà déjà
mon évaluation de 30% on va passer à 10
six personnes là et ça on prend le
chemin
mais surtout qu'il a vraiment mal joué
il a pas vu des tactique facile quoi non
non franchement le cavalier 4 je l'avais
sur foot3 de base et le dame prend B2 il
est pas si facile mais tu dois pas
laisser dame B4 échec arriver en fait
non mais il est pas très dur dans le
premier
c'était focus ou quoi c'est juste c'est
un O'Brien
[Musique]
c'est pas terrible
ok
donc on a plus de 10 % j'ai envie de
dire on va voir c'est de la ce que ça
donne
ouais ouais mais moi ce qui m'inquiète
pour Manu c'est plus que il est pas au
niveau quoi
tu es un peu un match à sens unique en
fait il sera accroché comme il a pu mais
sans être en capacité de
de lutter aujourd'hui
faudra voir dans l'interview d'après
match qui dit bon sûrement rien de
spécial
je sais pas
iste il était malade ou pas quoi
ce que je trouve quand même assez
faible mais tu as toujours du mal à
savoir est-ce que c'est l'adversaire
qu'il a fait des jouets
je crois qu'il était quand même
ça vient de lui quand même
j'ai cette sensation aussi mais
après en plus je comptais bien qu'il va
bien jouer
et
à 3 mètres dedans en fait tu espères que
quand tu es pas dans ton assiette le mec
va pas trop te martyriser que tu arrêtes
à te mettre dedans
genre ça me fait penser à son début de
match entre un an dans 2000 quoi 13
il était vraiment pas dans le coup de 80
parties et en fait ah non il prenait pas
de risque
gagne une machin à papa c'était fini
en fait il faut aussi être capable de te
faire mal quand tu es pas dans le cou
quoi bien sûr
un moment tu te remets peut-être ou donc
c'est un peu franchement
j'ai réussi à l'amener jusqu'au bout sur
un match qui aurait été très très bien
géré
surtout que normalement Magnus il est en
confiance contre Ikaru il a plutôt de
bons résultats
peut-être
c'est là tu sens qu'il est pas il arrête
tout F3
pour jouer sur les surcharge
en plus il le voit enfin je sais pas
c'est pas très difficile
[Musique]
il est complètement à côté de la plaque
en fait parce que
ça peut pas ça peut pas être le truc
quand même
alors après il réussit quand même
sur le jeu à poser quelques problèmes
mais
j'espère pas
non mais là il joue juste mal
mais je crois qu'il arrive pas à
calculer en fait j'en sais rien c'est
étonnant et son fossés ça des
symptomatiques parce que je le vois pas
faire des
couilles pareil ouais
en fait son placement de pièces c'est
bon c'est du Magnus quoi
bon ben écoute finalement
c'est pas c'est pas contrôler quoi
absolument pas il va falloir finir quand
même parce que en tactique il va te
mettre des barbeles encore une fois
OK
un peu de bol quand même pour Magnus
dans celle-là mais bon écoute tant mieux
pour lui
du coup il repassera à 20%
il fait comme il veut alors là c'est une
balle de match pour Ricardo dans cette
partie femme j'ai raté
[Musique]
il était complètement gagnant c'était
terminé puis quatre points c'était fini
il revient à deux
il reste quoi il reste 23 minutes encore
donc tu as le temps
mais tu as l'impression qu'il est
tellement en dessous de son niveau max
il est quand même
la preuve des grands joueurs
aussi ça a l'air sympa mais son
placement de pièces naturelles est quand
même exceptionnel
je pense parce que là aujourd'hui tu as
vraiment l'impression qu'il arrive pas à
calculer mais c'est quand même les
pièces sont tout le temps bien en fait
ça c'est prodigieux
jusqu'à preuve du contraire Magnus n'est
pas le meilleur
ouais je sais pas en fait le lien juste
numéro 1 mondial depuis quasiment 15 ans
je sais pas trop ce qu'il a prouvé en
fait
je crois qu'il a rien à prouver à
personne Magnus
écoute c'est pas fait pour les carreaux
non parce que cette finale n'est pas
simple non
je sais pas s'il va pouvoir la gagner ça
là elle est pas facile quand même
non ça avait l'air mieux et quelques
coups que tu vas encore de 5 là
le roi est plus safe de toute façon avec
les Blancs tu peux aussi envoyer un h4h5
à un moment un peu
faire des machins là-bas
oups et ça abandonne direct pour les
carreaux ça commence à suer côté
américain
là il doit pas être bien quand même
parce qu'il sait que Magnus il est loin
de son niveau max
et ça suit
balancer les mains la poubelle j'ai
compris
mais ça peut être très bien jouer de la
part de Magnus parce que ça peut être un
vrai coup au moral ça Fab d'être allé
chercher nul
bah le truc c'est qu'en plus je pense
Manu ça va être à l'aise dans le genre
de position enfin c'est une page je
pense il est à l'aise il l'a travaillé
comme un ouf pour son match contre
népaud donc il va avoir les rêves et
donc même sans le calcul il va savoir il
va avoir les les coups quoi là ça se
voit qu'il se rappelle pas
pas le meilleur
il a l'air tellement emprunté
des deux trois derniers coups mais ça
t'a perdu fou et tu bloques mais bon il
va pas la gagner celle-là
même pas sûr qu'il fasse nul ça c'est
pas sûr mais en tout cas
[Musique]
peut-être trop ambitieux
il y a pas un damage 4 équipes
gagner celle-là c'est le remettrai du
large
mais bon c'est loin d'être fait mais
Magnus on a gagné une comme ça tout à
l'heure assez facilement d'ailleurs il y
a une plus dur
n'est pas terrible pour les noirs
[Musique]
à jouer
attention quand même
il est en train de tomber il est en
train de tomber
en fait il a réussi pas à jouer vite non
plus
si vous l'avez vu monter c'est que il y
avait
il y avait quelque chose de très fort
mais qui était quasi introuvable
tu as l'impression que tu es un Magnus
c'est en fait c'est Magnus freezer je ne
suis qu'à 1% de ma force
ok ça c'est un tout petit peu chiant
pour les noirs de mémoire
ouais je connais parce que je me l'a
déjà joué
des conneries ouais en fait ouais tu
peux aussi juste prendre ton front des
quatre il faut prendre le cadre d'un
point 4 et la tour des ouais j'ai eu
cette position exactement celle-là en
plus
tu vois j'ai pas analysé après mais ça
m'a fait chier il va te faire à chier va
te faire G3 il va te faire H4 il a la
colonne des enfin c'est chiant en fait
moi je sais que enfin je rappelle pas
exactement de cette partie là mais je
sais que ce genre de truc j'ai déjà
perdu sans jouer en fait
ouais voilà exactement comme ça
mais là juste ça se passe bien pourri
carreau parce qu'il a réussi à faire une
double attaque
mais c'est juste parce qu'il a piégé
sinon stratégiquement et il y a des
tours H6 c'est des trucs de partout
très mal joué manus quand même
mais bon après faut dire le niveau de
jeu est pas stratosphérique mais au
moins on a de l'intensité et de un
scénario avec de l'enjeu quoi
bah c'est marrant parce que
les deux jouaient mieux dans les dans
les autres matchs en fait et là j'ai
l'impression que ta Magnus empruntait
d'un côté et taikaru de l'autre côté qui
flippe un peu
il est bien joué pendant tout le début
du match mais là
tout d'un coup
fourchette il a pas vu le dame machin
pour gagner
qui laisse 3 c'est particulier quand
même
j'avais juste pu revenir avec ton D4
quoi
ok j'ai rien dit
parce que ça doit être nul facile non
quoique
ça
peut parler ok genre là il fait pas H5
qui était le coup de l'ordi mais qui est
assez facile quand même pour bloquer le
roi
[Musique]
ça c'est des énormes gaffes quand même
un Fab alors après c'est du Bullet il y
a peu de temps et tout s'explique mais
il est plein de secondes il est quand
même 30
c'est quand même le coup que tu fais
avec la main quoi
c'est pas un coup de difficile c'est un
cours réflexe il le fait maintenant
parce que c'est le coup
ça a l'air d'être bien gagné quand même
si tu arrives
dans ces quatre c'est roi des trois
je crois ouais
[Musique]
mais parti vraiment complet de Magnus
bah écoute je sais pas c'est chaud
très incertain en fait ça peut ça peut
passer d'un côté comme de l'autre femme
on va voir comment il continue
alors comment il va jouer ça mais bon je
pense qu'il carreau quand même va
prendre les dessus dans le sens où
je pense que finalement par greffer un
peu trop souvent
en fait c'est juste que je trouve que le
score est très flatteur
pour Magnus par rapport au contenu de ce
qu'on voit regarde même là il a de
nouveau 30 secondes de retard en fait je
comprends pas comment il s'accroche en
fait
et c'est la force du
vagin c'est la force des grands joueurs
de machin de tout ce que tu veux mais au
bout d'un moment
genre là il est encore foutu
sans faire grand-chose en fait
de procurer un match alors qu'il peut
pas jouer quoi ouais
vous avez France Argentine en fait non
mais vraiment finir par perdre quand
même et que en fait c'est incroyable de
pas juste avoir perdu et que on en parle
plus quoi
oui c'est ça c'est que tu te dis ok il
aurait vraiment avec ce niveau là il
pourrait être à moins 10 quoi
et il est que à moins et ouais
après peut-être qu'on a Lucine
complètement et Magnus est juste à son
niveau et il Caro a progressé et il fait
juste un gros match et on s'en rend pas
compte
[Musique]
il va encore tomber et ça refait deux
points d'écart
c'est peut-être la bonne cette fois
pourri carreaux
le match à 3 jours contre Maxime il
faisait des parties sans enfin c'était
hallucinant en fait
non
et ne pas la perdre
c'est tout l'inverse aujourd'hui mais
comme je disais est-ce que c'est Hikaru
du coup qui
qui joue particulièrement bien et qui
qui empêche
un Magnus de se mettre en place et ce
que Magnus
est en forme ça c'est on en saura
peut-être plus après le match
ce qui a provoque la faute probablement
mais j'ai quand même l'impression que
Magnus en fait beaucoup
même si certaines sont provoquées
défoncé ouais après
cette période hivernale
importante parce que si c'est plus 3 ça
fait trop mais là bon
position pas claire une carreau qui est
installé son client C4 donc qui bloque
un peu sa faiblesse et si il la cache
une
et surtout tu sais pas pourquoi mais
Caro il a de nouveau 30 secondes de plus
enfin 15 secondes de plus alors que tu
sais même pas où c'est où elle vient en
fait c'est ce qu'on en plus non
il joue plus vite il joue plus vite
de manière très directe et il joue
nettement plus rapidement
bien joué ça
il veut jouer la finale
il reste 8 minutes derrière donc il a le
temps il a le temps il a encore
je trouve que la finale c'est une bonne
tentative pour les blancs d'ailleurs il
l'a refuse la qualité 3 maintenant ça
peut aller vite
[Musique]
sa belle pièce en C4 mais bon qui est un
peu vide enfin qui maintenant du coup
attaque plus rien
mais bon il va falloir terminer ça et il
est encore placé une tactique
ok
H3 mais bon ça menace vous prend des
cinq et cahiers français 6 Fab trop mal
en fait tu as vraiment l'impression
qu'il va aucune tactique
mais que son placement de pièces et
exceptionnel
OK
ça fait mal quand même
parce que je pense que la finale elle
est trop facile
et ça c'est pas fait
il faut deux c'est bien joué ça fait une
focale
[Musique]
7 surmonter prend E2 B8 dames
aussi
de le faire quand même
quand même je sais pas si la raison ou
pas parce que dans il reste 6 minutes
encore
je sais pas
là je peux pas dire j'en sais rien c'est
une bonne idée ou pas
il a plus trop le score pour le gérer
mais bon ce qui va revenir à un point et
il va limiter ouais je sais pas comme il
a quand même pour moi Guy Carouge ou
mieux quand même sur sur le Bullet
et dans tous les cas il restera deux
parties il en restera pas une
allez Magnus qui joue la française
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée en ce
jour de défaite
en finale de la Coupe du Monde Fab je
l'ai déjà joué tout à l'heure
il est plus trop près de l'ouverture
mais je sais pas c'est quand même pas
fini par la perdre au final
c'était pas celle qu'il avait gagné
finalement avec les fous de couleur
opposés où il était repassé par perdant
et il y a eu un fou enfermé chez plus où
là en H7
je crois que c'était cette partie
c'est quand même plus sympa
il a du mal encore à jouer vite hein tu
vois regarde de nouveau 20 secondes de
retard et on a pas l'impression que les
coups fusent pour lui
c'est une balle de match pour icarbon en
revanche si il gagne celle-là c'est
terminé
il a la position pour
il va faire G3 et les cases blanches
sont hyper bien protégées autour du roi
je vais nettement plus vite
une nouvelle fois
il sort mieux des ouvertures
bref peut-être qu'on s'en rend pas
compte mais qu'il joue des prépas
ne le fait pas j'en sais rien c'est
difficile ça pour nous de juger
son répertoire principal et lui zéro
problème Magnus il prend un cercle
à 8 un truc comme ça
[Musique]
une belle partie mais un peu à l'image
du match finalement et c'est terminé
nado deux points d'écart 3-20 ça peut
voir plus revenir Fab un match étrange
d'abord mais peut-être que si l'un va
gagner vite non mais 3 minutes tu peux
pas
mathématiquement
de 30 coups quoi
il y a rien à dire
au final il aura bien fait de faire
durer la partie d'avant ouais
exactement
parce que voilà le truc c'est que
oui
mais oui ça a trop duré Fab ça a bien
trop durer mais ouais un match un match
bizarre je trouve
qu'il y aura jamais vraiment trouvé son
rythme
mais
c'est un peu trop en dessous aujourd'hui
tellement contre le cours du jeu il a
réussi à revenir à égalité c'est
incroyable
immédiatement exactement
il va encore se la gagner mais
il restera plus de temps
le vrai chrono
non tu peux pas gagner
ça doit être complètement gagnant à il
reste 50 secondes
qui va pouvoir jouer la montre jusqu'au
bout et qui remporte ce speech une
dernière partie vraiment à l'image de
tout le match au final Fab ça c'est
jamais vraiment emballé
ni dans le jeu ni dans l'attitude ni
nulle part en fait c'est comme ça
le temps perdu qui récompense Hikaru
c'était complexe bah écoute Fab merci
d'avoir suivi ce match en ma compagnie
le match est terminé et on se retrouve
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour de nouvelles aventures merci à tous
pour vos avoir les interviews merci au
revoir